I mean, dude, in today's day and age, I've seen I've seen 30year-olds
look like 15y olds. So, like, >> this is not a good start
for Techone. I don't know why he's starting there. Hanabi's on
the ground reporting. >> Let's extra Emily looks like she's
17. >> He's in there. He's in the trenches so you don't
have to be so he can lie to you about the things that are actually
happening there. Okay. >> Lily Pichu looks about 13 years
old.
>> Okay, bro. No, she doesn't. I'm like, uh, I get it,
right? Like, like here, here's an example, bro. Eie looks like
she's 16 years old, guys.
I think we go to the legal mindset video now, right?
Yes. Yes.
Oh, no. Wait, I lied. Not the legal mindset video. I just I want
to watch this real quick as a treat for myself. Okay, >> let's
go back. We'll watch this >> as a treat for myself.
Just as a treat for myself. Just a little treat for myself. Okay.
Oh, Twitch just really, dude. It's like Twitch and Kick both
do this thing where they crash. >> Oh, let's go back. We'll
watch this, right? So, this is this is >> little treat
to myself. I'm going to watch the Asmin Gold react to the Willie
thing. Just real quick, >> a crazy [__] Like,
apparently this happened yesterday. This is getting a lot more
serious than I thought it was going to be. Like yesterday, I
was not as sure, but like things are getting pretty serious.
Listen to this. >> It's because he continued to write,
"I didn't know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording blah
blah blah." And then he shows me a screenshot of the top of a
video clip and says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype
calls. That's absolutely insane to think about him doing all
of this if she was 17. Well, this >> So, um, Legal Mindset
made a comment about this. >> Oh, that's who we're going
to watch in just a little bit. Molly mindset himself. Uh, yes.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Stop. Did a whole video on
it this morning. Yeah. As I said, I mean, this is this is his
recounting of it. So, you know, I've got no problem really looking
at this, but in terms of like the specifics of it, um, you know,
I'm not trying to get into it. You think you got the full context
in that 4 secondond clip or no? The sassy chatter is coming for
what he said. So, yeah, kind of like I I've read comments about
this topic. Yeah, I kind of I kind of know what >> Yeah,
I kind of know what's going on. >> It's because he continued
to write. >> I mean, do you think that the Do you think
that the attorney had full context when he made that post? What
are you doing? I like Destiny. I hope this isn't true. I'm not
going to make any judgment on whether I think it's true or not.
>> I have no idea. >> Well, he kind of came out like
immediately and said it probably was true. Like basically all
of it was true.
>> Know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording blah
blah blah. And then he shows me a screenshot of the top of a
video clip and says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype
calls. That's absolutely insane to think about him doing all
of this if she was 17. Well, this is insane to me. >> Um,
I believe that they would have screen recorded Cyberdrifter and
then sent it to Destiny. I believe that would be the order of
operations here. Not 100% sure, but pretty sure >> because
he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP while sending me a screenshot
of the alleged CP. So, I asked to confirm if he just did that.
If you were sending me this, I'm guessing you still have that
video. Destiny replies, "Peppends on why you're asking, but yes,
I created copies of all of our messages and everything when that
court case started. Just to be clear, he's admitting to having
alleged CP downloaded on his computer. He literally has the video
open as I'm talking to him." I go, "Bro, there's been >> Uh,
so unfortunately,
you'd think that's bad. Okay. But unfortunately for Destiny,
he admitted to something far worse. He said that screenshot's
actually from when we we were trying to find her. Okay. So he
says, "No, no, no, no, no. That's not a screenshot from my VC
media player. I have that stuff like stored in a different hard
drive. That's a screenshot from when I got a group chat together
and I sent them screenshots of this CCM and I just pulled that
screenshot from that chat." Okay. Like jeez. I don't have it
like there anymore. I just But I did send it to all of these
guys who were trying to help me find that minor. >> Your
honor, he meant cyberpunk. Do not say that because then it's
going to get people to want me to play it again. Don't say that
word.
>> At least since my last video that she was underage and
you still have potential CP. >> That was a big problem
is like you guys kept saying we want, you know, please do CP
again. And I was like, >> am I crazy or is there like a
thunderstorm in Asmin Gold's background? Are you guys hearing
that? Are you picking that up? problem is like you guys kept
saying we want you know please do CP again and I was like
we know that the media D shared to the group chat wasn't censored.
I don't know that that matters honey duckling
that's claimed in the email and I believe there's some veracity
some backing up to that email right but I I've never claimed
that it's uncensored. I've said he is he has created artifacts
of that and put it in that group chat. >> [__]
stop saying that. stop saying that like cuz it was and you meant
cyberpunk.
>> He continues, I don't think I'm allowed to delete it,
lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/destroying evidence.
And I reply, talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me. >> I
actually don't know the answer to that. I mean, like cuz you
are supposed to preserve evidence whenever you're in a court
case and destroying evidence is bad, but also having that type
of evidence would be bad, too. I think that's an answer like
that's that's something that's like that's so complex. Like I
don't know the answer to that at all. this sort of stuff on their
computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed to. >> Debate.
Debate never changes. 10 years ago, I was watching Destiny claim
that isn't that big a deal. In 2025, I'm still watching Destiny
claim that isn't that big a deal.
>> Do or not. Isn't that something you want to confirm?
I continued. You just let me know you have CP videos saved to
your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was underage.
You still have them. Do you see how this is? So now I've confirmed
that this guy has child on his computer. In my 8 years of reaching
out to people over allegations, I've never had anyone admit that
to me. The last message he sent me was one. I don't even know
100% of her age was legitimately less than 18 when these were
taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure if he has child on his
computer. He's just 99% sure. Got it. Two, I'm pretty sure I
have an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case.
I've talked about it with my lawyer already. >> Dude, the
the number one does seem like particularly bad. I don't even
know 100% of her ages. This is after, by the way, the the the
Kiwi Farms revelation that she was 17, right? This is after that.
And he says, I don't even know 100% of her. The date is on the
file. The date is from a day. It's screen recorded before she's
18.
Okay. There's every reason to believe that she is a minor in
that screenshot. So, like, yes. I for a second like I wonder
if Willy's actually No, he is. Destiny is literally saying he's
like, I it's only like 99. It is only like 99, >> right?
Specifically with regards to the road. So, he went from I don't
know if I could delete this to my lawyer says it's totally fine
to keep. I don't know the law, but the idea that his lawyer would
tell him to hold on to CP for a civil case just doesn't seem
likely to me, I don't know. Law Tube can figure that out. Three,
if something were to come out of this, I don't know if I'd want
to wipe everything and not have something to turn over to the
authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political creator
is about to give a hypothetical, you know you're about to hear
some weird [__] If >> Oh no.
Okay. >> Hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever was actually
trafficking her or getting her to other dudes on video for him.
And if there was ever some kind of investigation into that, am
I hurting the chance of looking into him by deleting all of this
stuff? >> Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the CP is
because of a hypothetical
>> Like, let's just pretend that that hypothetical doesn't
apply to every single on planet Earth, right? Like every single
could technically argue that they're just holding on to that
CP so the producer of that CP could be effectively criminally
prosecuted one day. Listen, I'm just holding on to this because
I knew that one day if you wanted to ever go after this guy who
recorded this this sick disgusting freak, I was holding on to
it in case the cops wanted it. That's all I was doing with it,
guys. That's it. That's all. That's all we were doing here. Come
>> Case that he is not pursuing at all. Okay. Maybe these
reasons are legally sound advice that came from his lawyer. Maybe
he's lying and just saying anything to make it sound better to
me.
>> Surprised no one has gone after Vosch for own for owning
CP.
Uh do you have proof that Vos own CP or are you just calling
like Lollcon CP? Cuz obviously most places have very different
laws around drawn uh imagery of children versus actual imagery
of children.
Right? Lollon in the US is not CP. I have problems with lollycon.
Okay.
But I'm not going to pretend that it is anything close to actual.
That's insane. >> I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I just
know this guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 GB according
to him.
>> focusing on the 60GB thing? Um I I don't think this
is actually an example of Willy's bad reporting. Okay. I think
Desi left that pretty it seems pretty obvious from what he's
saying there that he is a I can understand the misunderstanding.
This is like one of the least bad versions of Willy's bad reporting
that's happened. Like this is something that you could reasonably
believe from the logs,
right? Like Willy's done way worse reporting in general than
this. But yes, this ends up not being 60 gigs he has on his computer
to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he doesn't
have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong somehow
make Destiny in the right? It makes no sense. For all he knows,
her boyfriend could have been 17 as well. Dude, you were 33.
I reported this to the police and recorded my interactions and
calls with the detective. >> William, how you doing as
officer? Okay. >> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again.
>> Great question.
>> Screenshots or copies of the
Well, as I said, uh, you know, he continued to write until it's
a pretty serious thing and, um, I I, you know, I don't want to
make a lot of comments on it or say anything, but, uh, yeah,
I have no idea. Passing the evidence to your lawyer on an external
hard drive would be a better option. I I mean, like, now that
somebody says that, it seems like that's the obvious common sense
better option. But, I mean, who the knows, man? Like, I I don't
know. I have no idea. And I got to imagine that that's a pretty
easy Google search, chat, GPT, whatever you want to do. Hey,
I have come to I've only just recently come into uh, you know,
materials that might be child sex abuse materials. I want to
report this to the authorities. How do I how do I do so? How
can I get this, you know, in somebody else's hands? I feel like
something tells you that almost immediately. No. >> So,
uh, yeah, that's at least the way I see it. That's what I'm looking
at. That's what I think. And so, yeah. Are you going to defend
them, Stone? Why would I defend him? Why would I Why would I
defend or attack him? >> People hate, but I wait at J's
dog. People hate, but I definitely understand the draw of Asmin.
He's like the guy at the bottom of the Midwit meme, and DG is
the Midwit, and I am the genius. Okay, he's like the guy with
the dented head. Okay, I got you. >> I'm not a court of
law. I don't have the purview of >> And he planned on streaming
today, but of course she no showed. Yeah, >> the legal
evidence that's provided to >> I all I can say is if it
it would just be weird to me if she came out was like I have
no connection to Destiny after the after the display with America.
to them I don't know that I'm not an investigator. How could
I have any idea at all about this? This is not my job. Like that's
it. Like I I'm not going to do that. Vanna Cedar. Yes. No, she
can't stand by this. But now, Zuul, the issue is now there's
something she can't stand by that she's going to want to distance
from. But instead of instead of just distancing, she's probably
going to get really mad. Okay. Really, really mad at anybody
who goes, "Wait, weren't you like back with this guy? Weren't
you totally standing with this guy through all these like allegations
and stuff? Did you actually like cut ties business-wise with
him? Did you like Well, uh, we'll see. Limbo gang, you know.
We'll see. And so this is Yeah, this is a legal issue. Exactly.
Like that. That's literally all there is to it. And as I said,
I I I know people want me to look at it, but that's pretty much
where we're at. Karen's and in
Cracker Barrel is dying. That's right,
Let me see if I can find it. What is this? Um,
are we good? We had a little bit of a hiccup there.
So Cracker Barrel was having a bit of a bad time.
>> Oh god. I I heard a little bit about this Crackle Cracker
Barrel woke stuff and I I had to I got to dip. Okay, I got to
dip. Want to bet NCS is a ride or die for Tiny. No, I don't.
Just needs to tell people she was working to get free healthcare
for all and defeat Trump. That is all that matters. Yeah, that's
why she was like, "You think Destiey's really smart, right? You
should come join our our our college our college age debater
movement." Okay, you're a woman. You're a woman. You're college
age. Can you come join our movement? Can you come be a part of
this movement with Destiny? Destiny's really smart. You think
Destiny's smart, right? I I'm going to lose it. Okay. Where's
my legal mindset video? I I've heard this legal mindset video
is not that good. Give me a second.
You know, would be funnier, maybe, probably, almost certainly
than the legal mindset video. Oh, nice. He's still He's still
leaning into it again. I've never seen somebody pull out of this.
Okay. This Destiny's Twitter bio now
or it's a meme. I'm not totally sure. Boot Chops just said she
wants to split from Destiny without backstabbing him. Uh, that's
rough. Okay, that's rough.
Didn't she just build a community >> that's entirely built
around not backstabbing Destiny? >> $3. Nice little pick
in stream chat for you Cracker Barrel fans. >> I Nobody's
a Crackle Cracker Barrel fan. What? Why? This isn't even funny.
God damn it, Reben. Now, why would they remove the cracker and
the barrel? Cracker barrel is rebranded. Get it? That's a cracker.
It's a white guy in a barrel. They removed the cracker and the
Oh, it's a meme. It is a meme. Okay. Sorry, I didn't I didn't
click through to go see. I just like reporting fake
>> I'm not going to play this game of every single Oh,
shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. I need to click
this uh this other clip. So, this will be interesting to see
if this works because I I could have sworn, didn't they? Like
they didn't build this community around her like analysis, right?
Like the analysis is totally failing. She couldn't even defend
the Destiny points that her his biggest fans wanted her to defend,
right? So, I don't know where she goes and gets anything to work
for herself,
right? This just doesn't work at all. Like at this point when
you when you're a logging my content and realistically you want
to separate from Desty cuz you've Dude I don't know I don't know
I just don't think it'll work
at the very end in the end I want to be able to have my own audience
you know it shouldn't be exclusively GGG
>> I want to be able to have my own audience and I think
I have the personality and streaming talent to actually achieve
my own fan base. >> I would say where do you argue with
your audience? Where do you like argue with these people and
say they're totally wrong? I haven't seen this person pull people
in and say like, "You're totally wrong on this, DG. Come and
argue with me." Now, that was like the most fun thing when I
had DJers who would come in. I'm talking about before I uh before
I'd left that community. That was like the most fun thing was
just to be like, "No, actually, I don't think Trump incited a
riot. [__] you guys." >> Oh, thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. >> I've got food now. Let's go. Totally
ready. Eight more hours to stream. >> Is that the way that
other people separate But like I I did that stuff. I don't know
if um I don't know if they've ever done this >> themselves
from Destiny is by betraying him. I think that is what happens.
You know, as somebody who is very familiar with this space
>> as somebody who um you know has seen betrayals and backstabs
over and over again for various reasons, but I want to be able
to separate eventually if possible without doing that. Okay.
Unironically. Seriously.
Okay. turn me off
at the very end. In the end, I watch if possible.
If possible, I'm guessing the fact that these people are watching
a when Destiny's also accused of of a minor. I'm guessing that's
going to start to hit some of these people, but you never know.
Maybe not. Maybe that'll never hit those people. This does not
sound like they're planning an exit at all, Ry, though. Just
so you know, that's like not what this is at all. They're not
planning an exit. They're saying it would be nice to one day
not have to rely on Destiny for an audience. That's all they're
saying. Just so you know,
they're not saying they're planning to exit. They're not saying
they are disavowing Destiny. There's nothing like that. That's
not going on here at all. Just to be clear, uh, what are we doing?
What are we doing? Got some legal mindset stuff. I'll find that
video. And then, oh, there's also the Tree video. One second.
Tree was covering this tonight. I'm sure there could be funny
clips from this. I got sent another clip from Tree. You guys
want to get caught up in the minutia of, "Oh, what if she was
legal? What if she I don't give a she's 19 years old. She still
got a teen in her age." Destiny himself said, "If you were over
30, you going after a teenager. You yourself is a repeating him."
By the way, I agree with that past
>> Old man in your 30s ain't supposed to be going after
no goddamn teenager.
>> The like who? Like,
>> no. No, no, no hate towards you teenagers, but e. That's
why I'm saying I'm glad I'm a woman. I'm glad I was not born
with XY chromosomes cuz I've never in my life ever ever ever
in my life did I look at some teenage boy and go
sure would love that between my legs. The hell I'mma do with
some little boy 19 years old. What the hell am I going to do
with a 21year-old? >> Speaking of Zena, what's up with
Zena? Speaking of Zena, what's going on with her? I'm sure there's
some funny moments for this stream,
right? Oh, wait. She's actually talking about Zena. Jesus. I
thought she was talking about Destiny here. Yeah, Destiny reported
to the police. I just see DG.
Why'd you pull up Leon the professional? Why'd she pull it up?
Zena, I heard Zena got a music deal. Yeah, I heard Icy say that.
Okay,
what are we looking for here? Legal Mindset. Okay, we've got
Legal Mindset's video and his stream. Is the stream good? Oh,
damn. We got a new DG breaking new DG logo just dropped.
exclusive. Exclusive exclusive logo.
Let's go.
They're like uh they're like little spies. They're like little
spies.
Damn.
We ever If we ever get debates with these people again, we'll
uh we'll maybe look at using it. It's almost as good as the foaming
at the mouth guy. How much did this pay you for this redesign?
This is like some artist in the community did this for for free.
Just for fun. Just for funsies, boys. Oh, this is the clip from
earlier real quick. BX77.
Who disagrees with Britney? Who disagrees with Britney? >> Well,
if you just because you >> Yes, it does. Yes, it does.
I disagree.
People who were victims of >> Wait, no. But I think Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. So, do we want to watch FastFax? Cuz I'm sure
FastFax will suck. He did a stream about it. Maybe the stream
is better. What do you guys >> And, you know, obey the
rules. No caps, none of that. Uh, no trying to bait drama in
here. Uh, that's not what we're doing today. But be sensitive,
be thoughtful in both the live chat and in the comments. Uh,
and I would >> we've got legal mindset. Okay, legal mindset.
Maybe the most qualified human on planet Earth to
to deal with this Destiny allegation. Okay,
he's I cannot argue with his qualifications. Okay, on the legal
side, I'm very suspicious in terms of how much knowledge he has
of what qualifies as in any given district of the United States.
I don't trust anybody more. Okay. I've never found somebody I
could trust more. I'm sure he's got every single law, every age
of consent down. Okay. I trust this guy completely on that front.
So,
>> appreciate that. Do it for me, guys. Do it for me. Um,
okay. Let's get some of these super chats first and we'll keep
going. Doug Diaz gifted five legal mindset memberships. Thank
you so much.
>> Danielle and JP
Rocks Church
that lawsuit. Uh, you can um you can go and check my previous
video, right? This is not a Pixie lawsuit update because frankly
there isn't an update yet from Pixie's lawsuit materially. There
may be at a certain point but right now I don't have something
to that I want to present on this this controversy and this repercussions
are going to go outside of Pixie's lawsuit. Now they may relate
to it in terms of discovery in terms of Pixie lawyers going hard
in the paint for information. Now that there's been kind of a
breach of privilege they can go after certain information. Yes.
But it's not specifically about that because image of
Apparently, this is where it gets good, guys. Okay. >> Period.
They not have even one image of
period. The only people who are allowed to possess are the government,
right? That's it. If you know something, if you know, if you
have actual knowledge that this is,
you cannot have it. >> Okay. What's actual knowledge though?
No. No. >> Cuz the whole the whole argument here is going
to be on suspicion, right? Like if you know 100% you can't have
it. Well, okay.
But what is what does knowledge here mean? >> That's that's
not a no. It's a no. >> Unfortunate question we have. >> Nobody
can have this except for the government when they're trying to
convict people. That's pretty much the only thing that that it's
done at that point, right? You cannot do that. That's that's
where people are wrong. And especially the the Florida circuit,
the Florida circuit has ruled that yes, you can definitely not
have this stuff. So this is pretty clear in the law. Now, there
are other circuits where there's there's arguments and debates,
but the Florida circuit where this be relevant, yes, that is
that is the rule, right? Not even one image. Not even one image
is okay. Right? So, yeah, that's that's the just the more legally
um interchangeable term because there's child exploitation materials,
child abuse materials. There's like different grades of it. So,
CSAM's something that is a part of like I think an actual legal
definition. They don't just put child laws. They don't say child
the law. I think >> YouTube can figure that out. Three,
if something were to come out of this, I don't know if I'd want
to wipe everything and not have something to turn over to the
authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political creator
is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about to hear
some weird. If hypothetically, her boy
Destiny should delete. Ethan was correct. No, Destiny shouldn't
delete without informing the first step is informing the authorities
and transferring the material. Then you should then you no longer
will possess it, right? You alert some authority. You transfer
the material
and then you remove yourself from the loop. You delete everything.
>> Boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her,
getting her to other dudes on video for him. And if there was
ever some kind of investigation into that, am I hurting the chance
of looking into him by deleting all of this stuff? >> Once
again, he doesn't have to talk about this stuff. And that just
digs him in deeper because now you're talking about trafficking
in C. It's just it's a whole It just digs him way way deeper
>> Yeah. Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the CP is because
of a hypothetical criminal case that he is not pursuing at all.
Okay, maybe these reasons are legally sound >> that he
also went on Twitter and said he could not pursue at all the
day before he had this conversation with Willie Mack. Literally
like 12 hours before having this conversation with Willie Mack,
he decided he was going to go argue. So maybe more like 18 hours
or something, he decided to go argue with Eli B on Twitter and
tell them I don't have anything to give the cops. I got
really. Are are you sure about that >> advice that came
from his lawyer? Maybe he's lying and just saying anything to
make it sound better to me. I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I
just know this guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 gigabytes
according to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he
doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong
somehow make Destiny in the right? >> And this is this
is the biggest one. I want to point this out here. This is massive.
If you guys have been paying attention, this is something that
all online streaming creators do and it's the most annoying thing
ever. It and it's it's totally wrong legally. And this is something
I want to point out. >> It is not a defense that somebody
else did it too and therefore I shouldn't get in trouble. >> This
is not a real thing. People online need to stop doing this because
it's ridiculous. Saying this other person did it so it's okay.
Like I can make a death threat because I had somebody death threat
me. No, no. It it both of them are wrong. You cannot make a death
threat and somebody death threatening you is not okay. You can't
do it back. And this is why, you know, people need to get in
their head cuz someone calls you a criminal. Let's say someone
called you a felon and said you were a a thief, right? And you're
a felon. It doesn't make it okay for you to turn back to them
and say, "Oh, by the way, I want you guys all to know that legal
mindset saying that you absolutely can't do this is actually
shaking my confidence that you can do this, okay? Or that you
can't do this." Like I'm actually starting to lean more towards
like uh maybe I should go maybe I should go inspect these >> Oh
well, you're a murderer, right? No, you've now defamed each other,
right? You've said something. Assuming both those things are
not true, right? Assuming they're not true, right? You've now
defamed each other. Two wrongs don't make a right. This is something
people's parents are supposed to teach you. Are we growing up
parentless? Like what's going Don't be a dick. I'll be a little
bit of a dick. Okay. I'll be a little bit of a dick. A little
bit of a dick. All right. This guy just rides the wave. He rides
the wave and just because we're in the wave, just because we're
a part of the wave, doesn't mean we should ride the wave, too.
Okay,
we don't like Destiny.
This guy is currently trying to appeal to customers who don't
like Destiny.
If you just watch this and you totally believe everything he
says, you're just falling for the grift. Okay, I'm just saying
he will I watched him go and just explicitly like make up about
the Ethan Klein case, right? Like he will he will just not address
material facts of that case. I can't remember the exact examples
right now. I watched him kind of make things up about the Destiny
case too originally, like what uh the actual revenge laws were
in Florida. Like he just read stuff into it that wasn't there.
Okay. He's he's doing content. He's primarily doing content and
he's trying to farm people that like basically, you know, people
who dislike the certain creator.
He's very good at it. All right. He's very good at it. I can
respect the hustle, but I don't always respect the facts. All
right. Yes. the visual depiction stuff >> going on here.
It's a basic tenant of the law that this is not the way that
works. You can't go to the court and say, "Well, he did it, too.
That never has worked ever legally, period." Right? Unless you're
under duress or you're forced to do it. That's different. But
that's not this situation here. He's not under duress, right?
Makes no sense. For all he knows, her boyfriend could have been
17 as well. Dude, you were 33. I reported this to the police
and recorded my interactions and calls with the
>> hello. Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great
question. >> You have uh screenshots or copies of the
>> when you guys spoke about having teleport and all that.
>> Yep. I also sent him my DMs with Destiny. I don't know
if anything will come from this. I don't >> I'll stop it
there because it kind of wraps up and I'll let you guys read
the rest of it's in the description. You can get it there. So,
it's been reported. So, um, let me get the super chats and then
we'll go into summary there and what's really important to take
away from that. Uh, first of all, the original venture says,
"Destiny call for the murder of people he disagrees with politically.
The most generous description I give him is domestic terrorist."
Once again, I'm I read every super chat, but this to me it can
be very relevant subjectively, maybe to you. And as I said with
the creators you watch, be your own judge. I'm not telling you
whether to watch Destiny or not. You may have a lot of good reasons
not to watch Destiny. This is about his legal repercussions.
So, I get it. You know, there we go. Uh, but uh, but that's that's
really not relevant legally here. I hate Yankee says, "Whoa,
>> Hold on. 2350, I think, is the next time stamp here.
2250. 2350. Give me a second. We're going to skip over to a time
stamp. 2350. 2320,
rather. 2320.
he talk to his lawyer? There is no way in hell that he told his
lawyer the whole truth. I I guarantee you there is no way in
hell that he told the lawyer all the relevant facts or he kept
his lawyer updated on this. If his lawyer knew about this, his
lawyer would never tell him to speak with a random streamer online
about this. >> Would never say to get online and start
blabbing off or defending people. Like his lawyer is probably
going crazy right now. And to be frank, he probably needs to
hire a new lawyer because this lawyer is probably specializing
in his civil suit. Now, he needs a lawyer that specializes in
uh, you know, defending this type of thing because this is a
very specific and uh, very ser
>> I feel like Andy B has the chops. Okay, he depends.
He defends one kind of predator, why not another? >> Serious
charge. And of course, I posted the meme. This is from the Niji.
For those who know my Niji Sanji era uh with the with the lawyers
telling Niji to shut up. I kind of repurposed that one over here.
If you guys didn't go here, this is um from Fork. It's kind of
repurposed. But you know, any lawyer, any lawyer, not just me,
would tell him to shut the hell up. Like this is just >> legal
mindset made a video on Destiny. Thank you, Hattyben. I'm totally
not banning you from the chat right now. nonsense that you would
get out there and you would be arguing with people on the internet.
Like this is not this is obvious, right? It's obvious. You don't
need to be a lawyer to know this, right? This is like common
sense.
Another uh another man says in him before he argues she was a
nudist. He's coping. Armor Viper says, "What's the punishment
in Destiny state if he's found guilty?" Well, we don't know what
what he's charged with. So, it's speculation. That's too speculative
for me right now. So, it could be years in prison. It could be
financial penalties. It could be who knows, you know? Who knows?
And then of course, you know, he could be sentenced as a first-
time offender. We we don't know exactly how this could happen.
We don't know whether they're even going to bring it. Once again,
uh if there's proof, then uh then obviously I think they will,
right? If it's confirmed, if they go in there and confirm, you
know, hey, this is all true, I think they will indeed bring the
>> It's it's got to be crazy, right? Again, I just want
to I just want to put this back out there. Like the the current
the current claim is
Destiny went to and what he seems to have he hasn't said 10.
Okay, 10 is from the email, but he claims we tried to find Rose.
Who is we, right? Where did they try to find Rose? And who is
he sending these images to? It seems like there's a group chat.
Seems like he kind of confirmed it. Okay.
Do we know this for 100% certainty? I don't know that we know
this 100%, but it seems like there's a lot of reason to believe
there's a group chat to find Rose.
seems to have sent those videos, screenshots from those videos
there. Dude, that in and of itself I feel like almost certainly
rises to a criminal if you didn't inform the cops. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Like I And he did this after the leaks happened when
probably there's every reason to believe that there would be
legal holds on a bunch of his data, right? Like there's every
reason to believe you could get sued. You could get held uh criminally
or civily liable for anything going on in those leaks.
There's every reason to believe your Discord DMs could be subpoenaed.
And he still made this group and he still shared these things.
I don't know if the members will be made public, Pub, but I think
um
boy oh boy, what do you do if you're somebody who was in there?
You're like, "Oh man, Destiny, I love Destiny. I'll help you
with anything, Destiny." you go join, you're like, "Uh,
what what what are we doing here?" Right? I hope, dude, I hope
that email is correct. And there's actual logs of people going,
"Hey, Destiny, uh, she might be underage, right? Do you mind
censoring her vagina for me so I don't get so I'm not holding
like actual like hardcore of a minor? Thanks, buddy. Thanks,
bud. Thanks for doing that for me, buddy." I'm just sitting here
and I'm like, if that log exists, that's that's pretty brutal,
dude. Uh, but we need the law enforcement to do that. And once
again, I know we're not always patient on the uh on the internet,
but we do need to be patient with law enforcement kind of doing
their thing. And let me bring up Destiny and
>> how he's impatient. Uh, cuz this is his biggest bane.
This is his response. Um, and this is his response kind of seething
at Ethan and Hassan. And this is everything that's wrong with
the internet is that this is something that clearly he didn't
run by his lawyer, but he should not be engaging in this sort
of argumentation. It doesn't help him at all. So he's saying
almost everything in this DM is wrong. Willie Mack is running
cover because he wants to get in with the boys and Ethan is trying
to distance himself from me because he's too weak to deal with
Hassan's attacks against him using me as a vector since he has
nothing of substance to contribute. I have no on my computer.
I've only complied with my legal obligations for my court cases.
The 60 gigabyte screenshot was related to a claim Rose made.
Someone whose name and birthday have yet to be reliably confirmed.
So, so here's the thing.
I believe that they will find these materials because I believe
Dusty's already claimed that he has them archived, right? If
he's got an
of the video
and he took a screenshot of that and he shared it after he was
informed by Solo that she might be underage and then he shared
it with multiple people, I think he's cooked.
That would be my contention. I think he's cooked in that case.
If they find and he's got all of the material to cook himself,
right? It turns out he did have an oven oven in his stomach and
he is using his tummy to bake himself. Okay. to totally cook
himself is nuts, right? He's archived the full videos. He took
a screenshot from one of the videos, it appears, right? Otherwise,
why didn't he just pose the log of Rose sending him that screenshot
or something? Right.
So, he has a video. He has a video that he believes could be
that he knows could be. He's been informed is by the person who
produced it. By who he believes produced it? Okay. Are you saying
he's his own invisible ingredient? Secret ingredient? Yes. What
did Oh, what did I just say about
Destiny had a response to Pisco in some argument they were having
that was, "Yeah, and if I had an oven in my tummy, I if I had
an oven in my stomach, I could use my tummy to break bread was
what he said." It's just a goofy quote. Just a goofy quote. So,
he's got the full video. He took a screenshot or somebody took
a screenshot. If Rose took that screenshot,
then he could just post that log, right? But he had that that
somewhere that he could take a screenshot and share it with people.
That means he was accessing it again. And if he at that point
had not informed the authorities, it's got to be ballgame. I
believe I believe that would have to be ballgame right there.
Who the [__] thinks of saying that? Really truly
disgusting guy. >> What he's trying to say is, oh, the
internet confirming it is not reliable, so I don't believe that.
Well, guess what? Now you're going to have the police confirming
that. And now you're gonna and if the police confirm that, you're
[__] you're you're screwed. And I'm gonna put I'll
put it in the swear jar for this one. If the police confirm it,
he's [__] And I'm sorry children out there, big,
you know, kids, you know, grandma. I'm sorry I cursed there.
I'll put some in the swear jar for that one. But seriously, like
if he goes out here, you know, doubling and tripling down on
this and saying, "Okay, well, you know, all of this is related
to someone whose name not confirmed, but I have that data." He's
now tripling down that he has the data in public. All of this,
by the way, is admissible in court. All of this is missible in
court.
So, you know, it's it's not going to be be able to put the back
the the the cat back in the the box, so to say. Uh Lisa for five.
Thank you so much. Uh Leprechaun Gold for 20. Thank you. Carbon
for two. Uh says GG. Hammer says some would say it was his test.
Okay, you know what? This is not like generally a funny topic,
but that's actually funny. That's actually
funny.
>> That's a low bar for super chats right >> Thank
you, Ham. Your dad joke. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
>> wait, wait, wait, wait. Are Thank you for the two pounds.
Jay gets for five. Says Destiny is a collector. Enjoys showing
off his collection. Deleting the folder for him is like a comic
book collector tossing electricision. Yeah, but see the thing.
You can't collect Seam. You can't even have one image of it.
It's not a Yeah. Anyways, let's >> Honestly, Orange Kush,
I just wonder if Dan was in the um was in the group or if Dan
knew like, "Hey, no, don't include me in this [__]
right?" Why does he sound sad saying that?
Possibly. Cypot
Dan was involved.
Why not? Why not? I know Dan's been in some other sketchy group
chats. I I don't know, man. By the way, man, with Dan, would
that be I'm trying to think I'm trying to think of how I would
have expected Dan to work there. Cuz here's the thing about Dan.
I had I had Dan come on my stream and explain that Discord doesn't
preserve, right? Discord doesn't preserve and
they barely comply with subpoenas. Seemed like Dan was pretty
confident that he could just delete a [__] with Discord
and they would never catch him, right? Dan said he'd bury a body,
but he wouldn't join a sus group chat. I don't know. I'm going
to have my all relevant moment if Dan is in that group chat.
Man, I don't know. I feel like Dan's smart enough in a non- Destiny
case, right? If it was like me, okay, never would be, but if
it were me, I feel like Dan would be smart enough to go, "No,
I'm not going anywhere near that."
Right. But with Destiny, it seems like he doesn't make good decisions.
So, I don't know, ma'am. You say that, pensive goat. You say
that. I think the the thing that you're fighting against there
is Dan's want to be a part of the group and to be like leading
the charge. I don't know. I don't know how those two impulses
fight against each other. Okay.
I actually don't. I think Dan is smart enough to know that he
shouldn't be in that group, but I think there are some other
impulses there that fight against it. All right.
We'll go in this for like a little bit. Now, we're going to explain
some law. And once again, I hope you all can listen here. Everybody
can listen up. This is helpful for everybody. And this >> January
20th, 2025.
Redact.dev post a tutorial on how to delete Discord DMs in bulk
from both sides. Redact tutorial.
Wow. Wow. Very cool. I'm guessing that if Dan were a part of
that group chat, he would have had his messages getting deleted
within hours in that group chat.
That's my That's my guess. That's my assumption. If I had to
guess, I believe that would likely be within hours. Okay. Who's
smart?
>> People have my heart. >> Why did I go back to
this?
Okay, we're on legal mindset. I'm finding the next piece of content.
It might be Twitch. Um, it might be just the uh the Twitch viewbotting
stuff. I think that's pretty interesting. thing. I think we go
a little distance with that. We got 58 minutes left. We can go
with the Twitch viewing stuff, guys. We
three subs away. Two subs away. Tech reacted. Oh, there is some
probably some Techone reaction stuff. Maybe we watch Techone.
Okay, we're um we're two subs away from another hour on the stream,
guys. Let's go. Two subs. Two subs. Two subs. Any two subs? >> Not
helpful just in this case. It's helpful at large. Okay. With
everything. Let's talk about preservation of evidence first.
Channel fans know the term spoilation. Spoilation is a very real
duty. This is something that does exist. So death, how does this
guy not know that it's spolation?
It's not spoilation. It's spoliation.
How is the [__] lawyer not getting that word correct?
Or maybe I just
Hold on.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
I don't know. That's just odd. That's a little odd to is right
about this sort of >> it applies in the criminal context,
in the civil context. It applies to any evidence, physical, digital,
anything relevant to the case. If it can be potentially relevant,
that's probably the duty engages for spoilation of evidence.
You must protect the evidence, not tamper with it, destroy it,
alter it in any way. If you alter it, you hide it, you destroy
it, you do anything to it, that's punishable, including not just
by fines, but by criminal penalties. Okay? And and so yes, Destiny
did have to keep stuff related to the case. That's true. However,
however,
you cannot keep even one image of
that's that's what he's le that's what he doesn't get there.
That's what he doesn't get there. And and the other thing is
cander to the tribunal. So lawyers balance confidentiality with
cander to the tribunal. >> Pronounced bugle swab. Why >> court?
So you guys all understand, people understand confidentiality.
You've seen Breaking Bad where Saul Goodman says, "Put a dollar
in my pocket, right?" And confidentiality engage. You can tell
me whatever. >> Oh, I want to hear this one. Hold on. Hold
on. >> Technically,
technically,
yes, confidentiality is super strong.
But on paper, lawyers are supposed to disclose certain things
to the court. Even if it means breaching confidentiality, there
are certain things that when you know them, >> might be
buckled. when you know them, you have to disclose them. And that's
the problem here. And that's what he's not getting. So lawyers
get away with a lot because they can say, "I don't have true
knowledge." And they don't have to report a mere suspicion
actual knowledge. So what lawyers get away with, here's our little
trick. I'm going to teach you our trick. >> Our trick is
when you tell us something really bad, >> we usually say,
"I don't want to see it and I don't want to really know." You
just tell me the facts like overall and and I can say plausible
deniability.
I don't know where this is true or not. That's how lawyers can
get away with a lot. And there are lawyers on different ethical
scales. So there's lawyers that say, "Hey, I'm a goody two choose.
I'm a boy scout. If you tell me something and and I know it's
bad, I'm going to report it to the court." But here's the problem.
If you do that, you're not going to get a lot of clients cuz
clients aren't going to trust you. They're going to think they
can't. It's going to breach confidentiality. So a lot of lawyers
what they do is they lean heavily on the confidentiality side
and how do they >> do that is saying I don't want to actually
know don't actually show me so I can say oh well judge I didn't
really know I didn't know for sure and yes that would include
that would include anything right
man how awesome would it be
let me describe the scenario for you if likey did hear about
this and Destiny and him basically had a whole lawsuit of their
own where Destiny's like you told me I was okay to hold it and
he's like, "No, idiot. I I told you I didn't know. We didn't
know. You have to say you didn't know."
And then as soon as you did know, you have to go to the cops,
idiot. Like when they just fighting between them. Oh, let it
happen. Cuz Destiny's going to go, "Dude, my lawyer gave me bad
advice." He's going to make like the Trump He would make like
the Trump argument. My lawyer said it was okay. How am I supposed
to know I can't have child? My lawyer said it was okay. That
would be amazing. That would be >> So with Cece saying,
"Hey, I'm not sure whether this is not and we don't know what
this is. We don't know what these images are. We don't know who
this person is. There's a plausible deniability there. However,
what just happened? And once again, let me show you the PowerPoint
here. If you have if you discover criminal or fraudulent behavior,
if you discover client perjury or fraud in the court, you have
to report this to the court. You have to tell the court. So is
a crime. You would have to report that. The lawyer would have
to. So the second the lawyer knows that it's cease
a duty engages to say something about it. Somebody said mentioning
Roblox. I mean >> this will be actually could give us a
good insight into maybe Desi is communicating with Andy and maybe
he's saying I still don't know for 100% cuz we haven't like found
this person and yeah you post that evidence online but I don't
know. I don't that could be photoshopped like I don't know for
and eventually I'm guessing that goes in front of a jury and
the jury gets to decide on what they think you really knew right
at some point cuz like
to to me a reasonable person would go no no no no once once this
stuff comes out like obviously you did know right sure Destiny's
lawyer loves it more money more problems more problems more money
>> that's a whole other can of worms but you're not too
far off there right once you know you have to do something about
it so they pretend not to No, they put their head in their sand,
right? You can't put your head in the sand on this one if there's
facts out there that lead you to believe, yeah, there's proof
that this person is underage,
right? AJ said, "Are you ever going to stream on Only Fans to
better monetize your PP?" No. I know Tech wants it, but he's
not going to get it. Mitch says, "For five pounds, how are the
lawyers able to defend a client with CESM?" It's interesting.
Well, once again, lawyers have a duty of zealous advocacy. So
they can the so they can defend them by saying, "Well, client,
your honor, >> my client didn't know, right? That's how
they would defend them." Once again, I don't do this type of
defense. It's not my specialty. >> Hold on. Hold on. What's
What's the perfect music for this one? >> It's definitely
not my special. I'm just giving you the general overview. And
there's all sorts of lawyers that have defend all sorts of people,
right? We had OJ, Casey, Anthony, famous defense attorneys there.
Um, you know, all sorts of, you know, Jose Bayz in the in the
Anthony case. all sorts of famous attorneys out there that take
their ethical duty seriously and also the duty towards reasonable
doubt and saying, "Hey, we you you know, we've got this duty
uh and there's reasonable doubt and there's always the where
the
kick up the leaves and the magic is
Tell me your blue skies fade to gray. and tell me your passion's
gone away and I don't need no care and no standing in line just
to hit a new low. You're faking a smile with the coffee to go
and tell me your life's been way offline. You fall into pieces
every time and I don't need no care
cuz you had a bad day. You take one down. You sing a sad song
just to turn it around. You say you don't know. You tell me don't
lie. You a smile and you go for a ride. You had a bad day.
You're coming back down.
>> All right.
We like it. We like it either way. I can't see it. Queen said
he got a shout out from uh like Red Bar looked at pulled up one
of his quote tweets or some I think.
Not sure. Anyway,
>> just a uh cander the tribunal. That's a cander to chat.
I have a separate guys, I have a separate duty as a streamer,
a cander to chat. I'm very candid with chat. I'm honest with
you guys. I know what the [__] I'm talking about.
>> Um Okay, let's continue. So,
privilege waiver. Privilege waiver. So if information that was
protected by attorney client privilege is voluntarily
disclosed
meaning you are out there disclosing especially if you're disclosing
to a third party or the public the privilege is waved. Now there
is a difference between inadvertent accidental bro tech is just
farming destiny dude you got like he's got like some AI to make
people get mad
like some AI to make mad people people mad now they reported
Destiny to the police. What the is he doing?
legal mindset not quite as good. All right, I'll watch a >> So,
what's crazy is the stuff face to face with a guy called Destiny
because everybody I was getting barrageed by a lot of members
of the community saying I was too afraid to talk. >> Listen,
the people want the uh the Destiny mockery content. Okay, that's
what the people want right now and I'm inclined to agree and
continue. See you. Let's see what TechOne says. Okay, Aerodite
went out of her way to build the Teeone Destiny bridge. Surely,
surely Teeone wouldn't just burn that down, right? Surely >> to
this guy that I was ducking Destiny, that I was too afraid to
talk to this guy. And so I sat down and had a conversation with
him. Now, I'll be real. His chat was being and was saying that
I was I I lost the debate. It wasn't a debate. We had a casual
conversation, but I had a casual conversation with Destiny. And
all all in all, I thought things went pretty well. But, uh, after
getting to know the guy for about two to three hours, really
just kind of made my jaw drop when I just found out that another
content creator by the name of Willieback just put out a police
report on Destiny. So, let's talk about it and let's see what's
going on here. I reported Destiny to the police. This is not
clickbait and entirely has to do with the DMs he sent me a few
days ago. A Reddit post showed that the girl Destiny shared Pixie's
nudes with was seemingly confirmed that time. So, >> there's
no way he just throws that girl's face up. It's so up, dude.
It's actually so up. I
keep getting caught by it, too, cuz nobody cares. >> I
do what I usually do and reached out to get a comment. He said
the girl, Rose, told him she was 19 and in college at the time,
and that the leaker, Solo, who is her ex-boyfriend, confirmed
that she lied about her age to him. This is true. In similar
scandals, this is where people usually.
>> The odds of where is she going to make a statement?
I don't understand how she could make a statement. Has Arrodite
reacted yet? Erodite was supposed to stream tonight. She decided
not to stream. I believe she's waiting on some
>> Argue, is he lying? Did he actually know the age? Is
it his fault if he was catfish? I usually wait for all the details
to come out before I comment. This is not lying. >> Yeah,
I realize he doesn't give a [__] Donna Sloth, I realize
he he doesn't think about these things. He doesn't give a [__]
I realize that. I I will say that if a content creator is talking
to a woman underage because that woman lied to them, I do think
it is a gross amount of negligence.
But also, it's like I mean, dude, in today's day and age, I've
seen I've seen 30year-olds look like 15y olds. So, like >> this
is not a good start for Techone. I don't know why he's starting
there, guys. I've seen 30-year-olds look like 15year-olds. Okay.
Uh, have you thought about getting an eye exam?
Maybe you need some glasses. You need some contacts. You pretty
rich. You get laser eye surgery. I think there's like uh think
so. I think he that's what he means here. And
cuz there there's just no way if you actually mean this you talk
about it, right? I don't think >> your lawyers will recommend
that you do is you put it on a What does CP mean?
Combat points. Yeah, combat points in Pokemon. You put it on
a USB
and then you surrender that to your lawyers.
You don't keep that [__] on your PC. >> No,
he he might actually
he might actually mean what we're talking about here. Jesus.
>> Right. So like so like for example, let's say you're
involved in like a case or like a case. Uh but you have videos
of those acts and they're completely consensual. You don't keep
them your
he's using this to say I actually have evidence that my ex is
lying when she went to the cops about me.
That's weird to say that you would have the exact footage. But
and then did she consent to that footage being recorded? I don't
know >> yourself. You put them onto a USB and then you
surrender that to your lawyers. You don't keep that on yourself.
Now, let's keep going here. >> I don't think I'm allowed
to delete it. lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/destroying
evidence. And I >> He did just say consensual. He just
described his precise um the precise allegations of his ex and
his precise response. I'm I'm It was legal. It was consensual,
right? And he's saying he has he has what do you call it?
It was legal. It was consensual. And I have footage of it. That's
that he's building up a hypothetical that applies to his exact
allegations. That's what he's talking about. like talk to a lawyer
that seems >> Can you explain what Tekk's allegations are?
He just explained it. He had an ex who says she uh he assaulted
her that she didn't want to give him oral and he forced her head
down and forcibly penetrated her mouth. I believe that is the
allegation, right? She didn't want to have sex. He did that and
he's saying, "Uh, that's a lie. I didn't do that." And also,
I have videos of us doing it, so I can prove it. That's what
he's saying here.
>> Is crazy to me. Who keeps this sort of stuff on their
computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed to or not?
Isn't that something you want to Hold on. What is this? What
is this? What is this? What is this?
>> Jesus. All right. I That was That was not the song I
expected. I'll be I'll be >> Continued. You just let me
know you have CP videos saved to your computer. You knew it was
alleged that she was underage. You still have them. >> Destiny
and Willie Cousins or >> Do you see how this is? So now
>> Trust me, Slime, I realize you just got here. Okay.
You hadn't been here for a while. We've watched the red bar
cover of Cousins like a thousand times on stream. Okay. I I can't
expose people to it right now. >> I've confirmed that this
guy has to confirm. I continued. You just let me know you have
CP videos saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that
she was You still have >> We had to take a road trip the
other day and uh I made her listen to this song. I made her listen
to the red bar version of Cousins. >> Do you see how this
is? So now I've confirmed that this guy has child porn on his
>> I also sang it to her while looking directly in her
eyes on the on the road. Okay.
And she didn't like that. She didn't appreciate that at all.
>> Computer in my 8 years of reaching out to people over
allegations. I've never had anyone admit that to me. The last
message he sent me was one. I don't even know 100% of her age
was legitimately less than 18 when these were taken. So basically
he's not 100% sure if he has child on his computer. He's just
99% sure. Got it. Two. I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to
preserve stuff related to my court case. I've talked about it
with my lawyer already, specifically with regards to the Rose
stuff. So, he went from I don't know if I could delete this to
my lawyer says it's totally fine to keep. I don't know the law,
but the idea that his lawyer would tell him to >> I can
kind of hit them. Canadian caller. I'm probably not going to
do it now. I've drank a bunch of pop for this stream instead
of water, so not totally >> Hold on to CP for a civil case
just doesn't seem likely to me. I don't know. Law Tube can figure
that out. Three, if something were to come out of this, I don't
know if I'd want to wipe everything and not have something to
turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political
creator is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about
to hear some weird. If hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever
was actually trafficking her or getting her to other dudes on
video for him, and if there was ever some kind of investigation
into that, am I hurting the chance of looking into him by deleting
all of this stuff? Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the CP
is because of a hypothetical criminal case that he is not pursuing
at all. Okay, maybe these reasons are legally sound advice that
came from his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and just saying anything
to make it sound better. >> Yeah, I I'll be real. If the
idea that CP was on my computer at all, I would delete that [__]
immediately, even if there was a court case. Because I'm pretty
sure the judge isn't going to be like, "So, why didn't you keep
it?"
>> Yes, I was. I was the person driving. >> Immediately,
even if there was a court case, because I'm pretty sure the judge
isn't going to be like, "So, why didn't you keep it?" Oh, yeah.
Because nobody wants to see that [__] Wait, no. The
judge is probably not going to say that. The judge's probably
going to be like, "Why didn't you alert the authorities?"
That's I'm sorry. That has to be the only play. And if you think
about it for more than two seconds, you have to know that like
alerting the authorities is the only thing you do there, right?
You have to make sure you don't let it go and go, "Oh, well,
it's just a little child amongst friends." No, somebody has to
somebody has to deal with that. Somebody has to touch the Somebody
has to
I was going to say touch the uranium. It's like the Chernobyl
thing, right? Somebody's got to actually go down into the radioactive
area and deal with that [__] Somebody's got to do
it. >> Uh, legal mindset was telling Destiny to shut up.
Reviving this very appropriate meme stream coming soon. Shut
up. Shut up. Shut up. Holy. Shut up. Oh man. Oh >> I don't
know. I'm not a lawyer. I just know this. Admitting to having
CP in my DMs. 60 GB according to him. Seriously, how does he
know the amount if he doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend
being in the wrong? Somehow named Destiny in the right. It makes
no sense. For all he knows, her boyfriend could have been 17
as well. Dude, you were 33. I reported this to the police and
recorded my interactions and calls with the detective. >> Hello.
Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great question. >> You
had uh screenshots or copies of the
>> When you guys >> Side note, isn't it always crazy
how streamers go from looking like really nice to just weird
creepy with the change of one camera angle? You know what I mean?
Like it it is how nice and presentable everybody looks and then
wone. What? like, "Oh, normal cam. We just look weird." It's
like Asmin Gold going online to offline. Like, he goes online
from like this aura, this red merc around him to like
some goofy dork in real life.
>> Bro,
I don't think Asmin Gold changes at all. I think Asmin Gold looks
the exact same on stream, off stream.
>> Yeah, Mr. Beast and Mr. Yeast. Oh, even me, bro. Even
me, bro. My lighting is insane. Um, what you guys spoke about
being teleported and all that? >> Yep. I also sent him
my DMs with Destiny. I don't know if anything will come from
this. I don't like leaking DMs as me respecting what creators
want on and off the record allows me to talk to all sides of
the situation builds trust with the creator and also allows me
to get follow-up statements for when the drama develops. But
when you tell me that you're in possession of and going to I
don't know why he spends a lot of time talking like this. I think
pretty much everybody's right. Everybody's cool with like I won't
leak DMs except if you tell me you have child porn. I pretty
much everybody's cool with that. No, I'm trying to think of somebody
who's not cool with that. I I don't think I'd be cool with that
person. >> Remain in possession of CP. That confidentiality
is over. I shouldn't even need to say that. If Destiny ends up
being legally in the right to keep it, then fair enough. If he
ends up getting charged, then I'm glad I did something. I'm just
trying to do the right thing in a situation I've never been in
before. >> Yeah, I think that's pretty damn fair. Well,
now you can't be the Destiny's allegations. Willie is best friend's
friend with Destiny and won't call him out. Crowd is oddly sign
right now. reporting des was the right thing to do. Making this
video was stupid. You don't know all the details. You couldn't
wait for the police to do their job. This is grandstanding. Uh
I >> Oh, that is uh
Sorry, John Doe with an extremely relevant point.
I If anybody wants to challenge this, go ahead. Why the [__]
Why the [__] would you publish a video on this? Can
somebody tell me that? Isn't that like not the right thing to
do? I feel like that's not the right thing to do to like immediately
publish a video. And it's after the DMs, so it's act after August
20th. Like that is actually a that to me I can't rationalize
publishing the video. It's the right thing to do if your intentions
are money. He's just reporting the truth. I'm just saying,
Dude, I'm just
>> I will say I can actually agree with this comment that
reporting was >> evil Johnny Bravo. Let's say it takes
the cops uh too long to form to get subpoenas now. Somebody deleted
their messages like um as soon as that video dropped, right?
And they they miss a bunch of people in that group chat. Wouldn't
that be bad? Wouldn't you want to give the time the cops time
to work to investigate stuff? Why shouldn't he make Hold on.
You guys understand it's to give the cops time to investigate,
right? That that's why making that video stupid. Anyway, >> the
right thing to do. The video is questionable, but we're going
to say uh Destiny has legally trapped FastFax. We're going to
watch that next. Uh we have some other YouTubers weigh in on
this. Actually curious what a lawyer thinks. That's enough to
be its own video. We'll watch that right now. Dan Salman announced
that he's stepping back from any else anything else podcast.
So this is uh Destiny's
co-host of a podcast. Uh which is if you've been living under
Iraq, I stepped back from AE. For anyone who pay for that sub,
especially a yearly sub, I'll be handling refund. >> Discord
has a 30-day retention policy publicly is what they state peub.
They retain messages for 30 days. With regards to Destiny, you
might be fine, right? Cuz he's probably already got his stuff
on hold
>> shortly and disabled new signups. Thank you all for
your support over the years. It means a ton to me. This is a
very interesting time to remind people that you step back from
a podcast with him. >> uh Ozel, how could that be an accusation?
If he just reports it to the police and and gets an artifact
of that, how could that possibly be an accusation? He can literally
just report it to the cops. And am I crazy? Or is it like I I
feel like on the other side of that you're kind of prioritizing
your reputation over an investigation. I But maybe not. I don't
know. >> We're going to see what happens with that as >> I
I do actually know. Uh I do actually know. Like come on. Just
use your [__] common sense.
>> Gold shares his thoughts on the Destiny scandal. Let's
see what he has to say. I'm going to give a hot take, guys. I
think Child is bad. Despite what uh the anime community and what
Nara's community will say, I think child is very bad. I think
that as a content creator,
this is just like my opinion. >> Use a chat for that guy.
>> If their age starts with one and your age starts with
three, stop. >> Techone. Really want to put that one on
the record? I don't know about that.
Listen. Listen to the reticence there. The pause and the reticence.
>> And your age starts with three. Stop. >> Yep.
Yep. Absolutely agree. I feel like if you're in your 18s, 19s,
you shouldn't be talking to anybody in your 30s. Now, if you're
tw >> Hold on. What about if you're in your 30s and you're
talking to somebody who's in their 18s and 19s? We got a lot
of condemnation for that, right? >> Like, if you're in
your 20s, I get it. I I do this rule where I'm 31, right? So,
I divide my age by two. >> I came up with this really neat
idea of like dividing my age by two and adding seven. And I find
that that puts me in a pretty good range overall. Like I don't
really get into any trouble. I just came up with this really
cool idea. I don't know if you guys have heard of it. Okay. I
kind of been putting it out there for other people to use maybe.
>> And then I add seven. Now this works
pretty damn well for like ages above like 22, right? Cuz if you're
22, divide in half plus 7, 18, right? 22 and 18 isn't really
that weird. Um, so for example, me, I would never date anybody
below 23. Yeah. Why >> date? D date. I don't think Destiny's
accused of dating this girl. Date >> seven. It's just kind
of the thing for like determining what's the youngest you should
date. It's like a >> date. Date.
Date.
I'll just say there's a lot of stories flowing around the Austin
sphere about TeeOne. Okay.
Now, I don't have confirmation on any of them, but I would just
imagine there are probably some examples of some people who are
possibly under the age of 20. Not under the age of 18, by the
way. Nothing like that. I don't know anything like that. I just
get the feeling that under the age of 20, possibly who've had
like little interactions with Techone. Okay. >> Formula
that's been used for a very long time. Yeah. I don't know why
uh that formula actually works also true. People thought the
Pixie lawsuit against Destiny uh would be career ending and all
it did was prove she was nuts working with Kiwi Farm. Well, we're
going to have to see the development of >> Oh, look. is
a DJ.
>> Joey Dubs. Joey Dubs.
People thought the Pixie lawsuit against Destiny would be career
ending. And all it did was prove she was nuts working with Kiwi
Farms community. Dude, also wait until this guy figures out that
apparently Rose was also working with Kiwi Farms to entrap Destiny,
make him look like a Can you believe that Kiwi Farms did this
to him? Can you believe that Kiwi Farms basically convinced him?
They they made fake evidence that of of an ID that showed she
was above 18 and then they took it away. They deleted that message.
Why did Kiwi Farms do this? >> Would be career ending.
And all it did was prove she was nuts working with Kiwi Farm.
Well, we're going to have to see the development of this case,
right? Let's keep going here. >> Just stop.
>> It doesn't matter what the reason is or
>> cuz let's just be real, a 34y old talking to a 19year-old,
that's weird. Now, it's not illegal.
It's not illegal.
But then a 334 year old talking to a 17-y old. Well, now we're
we're talking crimes, right? Now we're talking crimes. So we
got to determine I mean either that's actually not necessarily
true. I believe the thing that So in Florida, yes,
but like there would be states where that would be fine, right?
The issue is when you're dealing with with recorded
materials,
that's that's a hard line. Okay. 18 plus only. All right. Essie
used to claim it was weird, too. It is weird. But then you, you
know, you marry a Swedish girl who's who you met when she was
19 and you were 30, right? You know, things happen. Things happen.
>> way,
either it's weird or it's a crime. And there's pretty much that's
it, >> You know, just stop under. Yeah. >> I'm pretty
sure they were Wait, what are you talking about, Izzy? Pretty
sure they were on who? Even before Willy's video. I don't even
know what you're saying there. >> And uh it's happened
before. Yeah, sure. And it's too big to fail uh at this point.
Is it too big to fail? >> I'm 33. I think talking to a
20-year-old would be weird. >> Well, if you're 33 and you
divided your age by two, that's 26.5. So, if you're 33, you shouldn't
be dating anyone underneath like 24. >> Yeah. And I think
I think everybody would agree 33 and 24 isn't really that >> Um,
no. No. Leonard DiCaprio disagrees with you. I mean, usually
he dates women that are in their early 20s. I mean, to be fair,
I mean, so actually he doesn't, but yeah. I mean, I'm just saying
in >> 18 and three. Yeah, sure. Your age. Uh, divide by
two plus 7. I don't even >> Is that not crazy? I I was
just talking about that. Like, genuinely, I said that exact same
thing. >> Sure. Your age. Uh, divide by two plus 7. I don't
even agree with that. >> I do. >> I I don't I mean
like I I think that really people just need to stop going and
it's like especially if you're like a content creator with a
big audience.
Well, Asmin, that formula would have worked because if Destiny
was 34 when he was talking to a 17-year-old, 34 divided by two
would be 17 plus 7 24, right? So, obviously, Destiny shouldn't
have been talking to anybody below 24, right? That's that's a
way to make it not >> Doing this is just, >> by the
way, Tone was just arguing that was his rule for dating, just
so we're >> You're you're making a mistake by doing this.
It's not too big to fail because having Cracker Barrel, I mean,
to be fair, Roblox is a lot bigger than Cracker Barrel, but yeah,
true. The inter content creators and their audience is the problem.
No. No, it's
>> So the big issue is with content creation
is a lot of people say this is that you become your ideology
and worldview remains the same from the moment that you become
a streamer. And why is that? When you become a streamer, your
life for a lot of instances
becomes very stagnant. You stop doing new things. a a lot of
streamers
where all they do is stream. They go live every day for like
eight hours and then they just edit YouTube videos and talk to
their editors. They talk to their communities. These people will
not grow as people from the moment they start content creation.
So the problem
that's uh okay >> is a lot of copyrers end up being attracted
to minors or young >> sorry he just says some wild things
sometimes that I got to pause on and >> younger people
due to the fact that mentally they are the same as they were
when they started their channels. This is why a lot of like Minecraft
YouTubers and Roblox YouTubers are going to have Well, let's
just be real. Like if you
>> Hold on. Is he like slightly cooking here? He might
be slightly
cooking. Isn't this what happened with Michael Jackson when people
argue that like Michael got like way too exposed to the adult
world when he was a kid? He never grew up. He just was a kid
always. I don't know. Maybe there's something to this. Maybe
there's it's like arrested development, right? Like there are
things that arrest your development channel at 13 and you become
ideology captured from and your worldview remains stagnant from
when you start your channel. As you grow, your audience stays
the same age. And guys, I'm just going to be real. If you started
a Minecraft channel at 13 and you're keeping doing that till
23 and what you do all day is make content for children, all
of your viewers are children, all of your friends are children,
who are you going to try and that's why I am sus as of any Minecraft
or Roblox content creator. I'm just going to be real. I I'm not
trying to deal with none of that, right? Because when all you
do is make content for kids, damn, bro, you must really like
kids. Uh, let's keep going. Same thing with gadget about categories.
By the way, there's another
>> Train clip for that tech tone statement. What? This
is actually a train clip. Hold on. >> True. And yeah, that's
pretty true. >> uh the true >> or want to put up
my John Trron John Tron absolutely decimating Destiny. Soy Destiny
talking to minors where you have Jon Trron having a wife and
kids. Massive W. I would like to say John Tron has some of the
best content on YouTube even though he's a white supremacist.
Who is it? Who is it? >> We get any like uh funny Sunday
reaction. I got to link the Sunday reaction and then I didn't
actually click into it and watch it. I'd probably check some
of that out. Let me see what we got here. What we got on the
clock? We are Oh, we're way over the limit for another hour.
Um 1 hour 1646.
I have to do some calculations here.
>> Who is it?
video, still one of the best videos of all time, as well as his
Phil Swift video. Destiny drops his tweet in response to Ethan
Klein's video about a
>> Claims Willie Max show is running cover to get back
in with the commentary community. Claims Ethan is trying to diss
himself because he's too weak to deal with. >> Also, soapbox,
thank you very much for the five gifted earlier. I didn't see
that. I have the kick alerts off cuz they I tend they tend to
just interrupt a lot. I need to hammer that out maybe after stream.
>> Dax, I think Peterson was right. You and Ela deserve
all the >> Who's Peterson? Peterson is Jordan Peterson
who told H3H3 that their audience would eat them alive eventually
>> self because he's too weak to deal with Assad's attacks.
I think Peterson was right. You and Ela deserve all the CPS
That is a
that is a pretty rough thing to say. Uh almost everything in
this DM is wrong. Willie Mack is running cover because he wants
to get in with the boys again. 9/11. Sorry. Let me call back.
My OBS wasn't recording. Lol. And Ethan is trying to distance
himself from me because he's too weak to deal with Assad's attacks
against him. >> Marty Epstein, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's >> using me as a vector since he has literally nothing
of substance to this arena. Assan's lack of intelligence is his
biggest insecurity that no amount of finest ride, hair dye, or
bathtub photo will compensate for. >> I have no my computer.
I've only complied with my legal obligation for my court cases.
The 16 GB screenshot was related to a claim the Rose person name.
Someone whose name and birthday have yet to be reliably confirmed.
>> I'm sorry. One piece of dog next to toys does not mean
you call CPS. Stop being Don't let your hate for Ethan Klein
blind you. Okay. One piece of dog [__] next to some
toys is not a CPS call. >> Ethan is literally reading off
revenge lakes of mine. And I >> do I does that really have
to be said? Are you guys that socially stunted that you go, "Oh,
well the dog next to the toys once. We need to call CPS immediately.
Shut the up. >> Giggling coughing means he's too lazy to
use his inhaler. Like a child for DMs, it had absolutely nothing
to do with the rose leak. Any reference to or orgies or anything
else was literally in the context of DMs of the 26-year-old British
woman. I've never DM'd that rose person on IG in my life. I think
Peterson was right. You and Ela deserve all the CPS calls
for the dog eating claims and everything else. You deserve zero
sympathy from anyone else on the internet when you're so quick
to turn around and rely on the same snark that's been plaguing
you for years as soon as you think it's beneficial. I hope your
prior maid takes you for a millie and her laws against you guys
as well. For anyone else watching, you'd assume that every single
influencer you meet on the internet is a terrible human being
with zero values or principles. See you tomorrow's room. I will
say in defense of Destiny here, I do think a lot of people are
quick to jump the gun. I think I think it's a bad look for Destiny,
but we still don't know the whole truth for Destiny yet. And
I'll be excited and looking forward to the updates of this [__]
because uh >> I would love for I would love for TechOne
to tell me what we're missing cuz realistically you could say
this
in my
analyzed any of this closely enough or been able to see the source
material before it was deleted to say that like all of those
birth marks are in like exactly the place they are in the photos
that I could pull up on Instagram directly, right? Like I know
there's like some
really really minuscule chance that you can't connect the Rose
person he was DMing who had the Twitter account that was selling
nudes to the the Instagram the public persona of this person,
right? I know there's some tiny tiny tiny chance there, but like
but like it's so minuscule that it's really not worth like speaking
about, right? I I don't think Tech has any idea what he's talking
about. He's just like, "We don't know the whole story yet, guys.
We really don't know exactly what's going on here, man. I don't
know. >> Who knows? >> Well, it would have to be
like malicious. And the thing is is like I just assume
I assume there would be like statements from people saying that
that's not true. Like there'd be somebody in the no that could
disprove some of this stuff or it would be disprovable.
Desie edited part of his tweet and added, "Ethan is a Zionist
and genocide supporter and the United States with loyalty to
Israel first." With Willie Mack then responding to Destiny with
Willie Mack saying, "I'm not doing this getting the good grace
of your anti community. I'm doing this because you admitted to
me in DMs that you in possession of CP. What you are saying publicly
is an entirely different story than our DMs. I have no on my
computer." weird because if when I asked Destiny had on his computer,
he told me depends why you're asking and then gave me a bunch
of reasons for why he can have on his computer. I will admit
either Destiny is lying or he has made himself out to look very
bad. Uh and that's all we know for now. >> Wait, but hold
on. You have to engage a little bit more there, right? Either
Destiny is lying. Okay, why would he lie? Who lies that they're
Who lies that they have Who lies in DMs about this? Who lies
about that? Why would you lie about that >> computer? I
will admit, >> God, I Mr. Girl. Mr. Girl. Okay. >> They
gave me a bunch of reasons for why he can have on his computer.
>> Mr. Girl would not either lying or he has made himself
out to look very bad. Uh, and that's all we know for now. >> Okay.
All right. All right. All right.
Doggy live. He's not. Okay. What's next? I think we go to Twitch
view buttoning stuff. Okay. like a couple different pieces here
for the Twitch view buttoning stuff. I might check out there's
probably be like like a decent Asmin Gold video that run through
some of it, too. I'll try to Give me a second. I'll cook up how
to go through this real quick. The original tweet is back here.
Okay, the original tweet was
Twitch announcing in June July June July June July June July
that they were going to crack down on view bots. A quick update
on view counts, guys. We have teams and tech dedicated to ensuring
that the views that show up on channels reflect actual viewership
and aren't artificially artificially inflated in any way. Ultimately,
metrics on Twitch should represent the real and growing communities
that show up and participate on channels. So, we regularly update
detection tools and methods. We recently made changes that meaningfully
improved our ability to identify viewbots in authentic viewership
and other potentially fake engagement. These changes will roll
out over the next few weeks. So, if your channel was viewed or
if some of your viewers are artificially or artificial or inflated,
you will see an impact to your channel's view count. This also
means that third party sites that publish unverified Twitch view
counts are going to see changes to that data over time. We recognize
that view botting can be out of the streamer's control. In making
these changes, our goal is to improve the experiences for both
streamers and viewers.
Train was all the way on board with this. If this is real, you've
done this and you've done this right. You're about to realize
80% of your top 100 new generation English-speaking streamers
are botting 50% or more of their viewership. First, they manufacture
false hype, and then they hide it behind collaborative events
that make the view count appear to make sense to the general
public or other real streamer. Holy, he had a whole bible here.
Damn.
Uh I've I've heard I've heard a lot of this stuff from Train
before. Kick has bought it hard. I think Kick just has a modifier.
Like I know it can be bought, but I think it just has a modifier,
too. Really? Like that's that's most of what I think it is. It's
just a like a modifier that's pretty heavy
on a lot of this stuff. Okay. All right. So, we go from there.
From there. Where did I start engaging with this? I think it
was the XQC stuff. The XQC stuff was like where I got onto this
in the first place. Okay. XQC is tweeting about it today.
I'm guessing he streamed about it today, too. Oh, JTO is viewed.
He has one guy with 100 alts at the same time just spamming chat.
True.
Kick his goat. It doesn't matter, though. Yeah, I just I I like
streaming on kick. Um, well, sometimes it's kind of, but sometimes
kind of Who do you think this is that he's actually looking at
here, by the way? Is this Mizzy or something?
I wonder. I wonder a little bit. Twitch has cracked down on bots
in the two in the two to three days in the last two to three
days and viewers/victims of viewing have been exposed. Streamers
that are part of groups/orgs are seemingly being being botted
much more heavily. I don't want to start witch hunts, but the
data is interesting. Go see for yourself. I want to know when
XQC called out Kai's buddy and Kai was like freaking out about
it and XQC was clearly correct. Has that guy streamed yet? Cuz
that guy clearly got called out by XQC and he was like so full
of it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The Kaisen guy got like insane
numbers on his phone. XQC was doing his own tweet thread about
it. No offense, dude, cuz regardless of your inflated numbers,
you'd still be one of the biggest streamers on kick. So, I never
understood it. But the second stream I clicked into yours, you
dropped 2K viewers in a matter of a minute. That screams inflation.
Ooh, damn. Damn.
I don't think I ever get these drops like this. I don't think
my viewership drops like this.
I don't think I ever get this. I also always have like a slow
ramp at the beginning of stream. So, want to expand? The guy's
saying that some view botting site manu uh malfunctioned and
dropped off totally when you play civ. No, wrong. When I play
S, I retain viewership. You're wrong. You're wrong. You're wrong.
You're wrong. You're wrong. You're wrong. You're wrong. You're
wrong. You're wrong. Still wrong. Okay, let's read the rest of
this thread and then I'm going to go look and see if we can find
uh some videos on this or something. Mostly cuz I have to go
get some caffeine and use the bathroom.
Asmin Gold. Did Asmin Gold cover Viewers today? He did. Oh, I
do think we have to cover Merror as well. Wait, is is there like
a mirror thread on live stream fail? I think there is. Right,
dude. Merror is the roughest case of this, isn't she?
Poor poor
poor Meera. Really? The biggest victim in all of this, right?
You know, did anyone I I So, I heard about Meera having like
the biggest um the biggest drop off. Oh, right. This is the video.
I have a video.
>> I'm shocked,
guys. Hey guys,
Charlie here. Uh, I'm really shocked that uh that so many people
were viewing on Twitch. It's like uh it's like bad. It's like
really bad out there, actually. Um, so, you know, we're we're
going to look into this. I've been growing up my beard a little
bit.
What do you guys think? I've been growing up my beard a little
bit. I think it looks pretty good.
I think it looks pretty good, actually. Yeah, I just I wanted
to throw that in there. But now,
now let's go back to the video. Um uh so Twitch view butting
it's really bad actually guys. It's really bad. >> I cannot
believe Twitch is actually finally making botbusting a priority
on the platform. Botting on Twitch has been a problem since the
beginning of time
and they hadn't taken it seriously forever. But a month ago they
made a statement where they claimed, "Listen guys, condoms finally
coming off. We're going in raw against bots. We're finally going
to do something about it." And I was excited. Like that's something
to celebrate, but I kind of thought they were just looking to
score some good boy points online, like some brownie points because
Twitch's reputation been kind of in the recently. I thought this
was just something that they were just doing for lip service.
I wasn't entirely convinced they were going to go that hard on
it until today.
Wow. They have actually done a really good job here, like in
this first wave of getting bots off of Twitch, like like bringing
back down these artificially boosted numbers to what they actually
are. There's a lot of examples to pull from. The data is all
very new, mind you, but I think the best example is from a channel
called Mirror. I'm sure some of you have at least heard of this
because this is something that people have been trying to put
on Twitch's plate for the
Zezy is in shambles right now. Zezy's in shambles. This is Zezy's
favorite streamer. Okay. Mera mirror on Twitch. That's Zezy's
favorite streamer by a mile. Zezy, if you don't know, former
Mitch Jones mod, so obviously was totally infatuated with Mitch
Jones's ex-girlfriend. And yes, listen, that is just facts, okay?
about a channel
that isn't actually a live stream.
It is just a
uh channel where Meera is just farming ads off botted numbers.
She doesn't actually even really stream on there. I think she's
gone live like a few times over the last couple years, but it's
live 24/7 just pumping reruns of streams she did so long ago.
Like ancient history. So, look at this. This channel for I think
like probably 3 years. I don't know how long it's been going
on for, but it's been years has been sitting at like a steady
2,000 viewers no matter the time of day. And all the channel
has done for this time pretty. You guys remember that Mira Hawaii
stream? That still blows my mind.
You guys remember that? Am I the only one who remembers that
Mirror Hawaii stream? We're all like, there's no way that could
be there's no way that could be toos. There's no way that could
be toos.
Oh, you guys don't know what I'm talking about. No, I'm not going
to go into it. I'm not going to go into it. Knowers know and
anyone who doesn't know doesn't know. But the knowowers know
pretty much >> pull it up. I don't think it's to on kick.
At least show us a pick. No, I don't think so. I don't think
I will. >> Is run 247 reruns of old streams yet somehow
manages to maintain 2,000 viewers throughout the entire duration
of it. Then the day that Twitch bot uh smiting comes into effect,
it goes from 2,000 then down to 1,500. And then the bot detection,
I guess, must have kicked into turbo drive. They went wombo style
and now she's sitting at 100 to 200
pretty much overnight. This to me is like the most clear example
of them actually doing something about botting. I was very surprised
to see this. her channel, which is live right now, by the way,
because it's 24/7 reruns.
This channel is constantly or was constantly recommended to anybody
with a brand new account. Like, see how I'm not logged in or
anything. I'm still on like light mode. This stream was recommended
all the time and somehow still had thousands of viewers on just
reruns.
Clearly, most like rational, sentient human beings aren't going
to be watching that. Like, look at the chat. It doesn't move.
And this is exactly what it looked like back then, too. No movement.
There's no chatting because it's not real. And now the bot detection
is here. And you can see that it is finally working. Though I
think there are still some bots, like some holdovers here, cuz
there's no way there's 250 people here right now. It seems to
me like there's definitely still some stubborn bots that Twitch
wasn't able to get there. Stick >> um
I'm guessing Twitch just uses a modifier based on like lurkers
or >> on there like a himmoroid. The parasite bot infestation
has been decimated but not destroyed cuz I cannot imagine 276
people being in this stream right now. Not even his background
noise in like a tab they forgot on like a
probably no sadder existence than a low viewer streamer. Dude,
low viewer streaming would be awesome. Okay, there's no sadder
existence than being like a high viewer streamer that then drops
to a low viewer streamer, right? Like if you're somebody who
got like thousands of viewers and you stream now to like 30 people,
that would be really sad. Okay, that would be rough. Streaming
to like 100 people or something when you're not never been bigger
than that. Like that's probably fun. I would imagine. >> An
ancient laptop. I don't even see that being the case. I like
I I don't think there is a single soul in this realm right now.
This is more empty than a theater showing MorbiiUs. Like I just
don't believe that. But even still, it's clear that what Twitch
is doing is actually pretty effective at blasting bots, which
I didn't expect. Her channel, I think, is the best example of
it. But there's a lot of other channels, like big streamers that
went live over the last day where their view counts have h haved
or even more than h haved in some cases. So, they actually are
taking it kind of seriously. I like I said, I was a little skeptical
that they were even going to really try and take down bots because
inflated viewer numbers is good for the platform. like I thought
they probably wouldn't actually put a lot of resources to it,
but it seems I was very wrong. Now, another thing worth mentioning,
this scam of like running reruns with bots is not exclusive to
just her channel, but you have to wonder how much money she made
off of that. This went on for years, and I'm so curious how much
money she made just running old streams 24/7 reruns with botted
view counts up to 2 to 3,000. That's probably a pretty substantial
chunk of change. It's got a lot of people talking and I think
this is a really great thing from Twitch to be honest. XQC made
a tweet talking about it saying Twitch cracked down on bots in
2 to 3 days and view botters/victims of view botting have been
exposed. Streamers that are part of groups/orgs are seemingly
being botted much more heavily. Don't want to start a witch hunt,
but the data is interesting. Go see for yourself. And
>> we're going to go into all of them. Okay, we'll we'll
go in. We'll go look. Ms. Kefs of interest. Tech of interest.
We've got a bunch of people. Okay. >> And Link's Twitch
tracker, which you can see for yourself. And people are scrubbing
through with a fine to
>> kick trying to benefit from inflated numbers, but they
turn the dial too high. Needed to make it less obvious. Why?
You understand Kick is the only person who pays for this, right?
Like, this is not like Twitch. Kick can change the viewer numbers
however much they want. Um, except I think
other than like a modifier, like I think it's like one and a
half times the viewers or something. Other than a modifier, I
don't think the kick numbers are too far >> Comb taking
a peek at these big drops in viewer numbers. And right now, the
findings are still pretty early because this has only been in
effect for like two maybe 3 days now. So, it's still >> Maximus,
are you thinking Kick could get sued for fraud? Kick can't get
sued for fraud. The only thing The only thing they can get sued
for is actually they can't get sued. They don't have sponsorships.
There's no ads, right? Kick just Kick doesn't have ads.
They're not defrauding anybody.
>> Like very fresh data this straight out of the oven.
But people are noticing that some of the biggest channels being
hit were affiliated with orgs. So like XQC mentions like some
org affiliated channels were
in a lot of cases the recipients of some artificially boosted
numbers as evident by a huge drop in viewer numbers over the
last couple days out of nowhere. Namely, OTK seems to be the
big one. People are seeing a huge drop across the board for most
of the channels that have gone live over the last couple days
that are with the >> Why doesn't is this guy talk are you
talking to me Maximus? Cuz like obviously the reason most sites
wouldn't want to do that is because then you're misrepresenting
to advertisers what they're actually advertising for or what
what they're doing. Right. Right. So you would have most platforms
would have advertisers. The reason they don't add this massive
modifier is because they want advertisers to have a good idea
of what they're advertising on. Right. If you're if you're running
an ad on a channel, you say there's a thousand viewers there,
you're lying to the advertiser. If you run, you know, a 30 secondond
ad and you get a thousand times 30 seconds, right? You have 500
minutes of ads. Not every website runs ads. Yeah, Rumble barely
runs ads. And I think they juice the [__] out of
their view counts. >> Another channel people been paying
very close attention to is Asmin Golds. He's one of the biggest
streamers in the world and he went live the last couple days
since the botfisting has come out from Twitch and they noticed
that his average viewers for both streams had been about 20,000
less than normal. About 20,000 people were banished to the >> That's
not 20,000.
That's like 15k, right? Okay, that one's 25, but
>> shadow realm here. And Asmin Gold even commented on
it believing that his account was probably botted. He believes
with 95% certainty his channel was botted. And he agrees that
removing these bot numbers and this fake phony baloney viewership
from the platform is good for everybody there. And that seems
to be the prevailing sentiment that everyone agrees that getting
rid of artificial viewership from Twitch is a net positive to
the entire platform. The only people that'll have an issue with
these fake numbers being blasted is going to be the people that
are exploiting them. The people that are using the bot services
are the only ones that are going to be outraged about it. Now,
I also imagine the cope from a lot of people that are going to
get caught red-handed with bots is going to be it wasn't me.
I I must have been the victim of a malicious
bot villain. A super villain twirling his evil cartoonish mustache
must have been botting me for all this time. I had no idea. And
in some cases, like that is a real thing. There are cases where
some people will bot a channel just because they think it's going
to get them in trouble. But that doesn't happen. Like Twitch
for the longest time has not taken this botting problem seriously.
So that whole idea of like a bad actor botting a channel to try
and get punishment put upon a streamer they don't like, it's
not that common. It happens, sure, but it's not that common because
everybody knows Twitch hasn't done anything about botters for
so long. So, how the could that possibly still be a strategy
that someone that doesn't like you would use? That's like you
and your buddy going to the public pool and you eat pizza together
and then your friend tries to tell the lifeguard that you didn't
wait 30 minutes before getting in the pool. It's like, okay,
who gives a like, that's the whole way Twitch has treated botting
for the longest time until now. I think that's going to be like
the crutch a lot of people will claim like I wasn't botting.
I didn't sign off on anyone botting me. This must have been some
stranger in the in the back alleys trying to hurt my reputation
by botting me for all this time. And some people I'm sure will
be telling the truth, but it's going to be hard to know for sure.
But one thing that I think everyone will know for sure is that
this is a really good thing for Twitch. I am so glad they're
actually taking this seriously. And
I think Twitch is probably having issues with advertisers, right?
Like that's that seems to be the most likely scenario is Twitch
was having issues with advertisers and they realized they had
to actually cut this out. Like advertisers just aren't getting
return on investment at all. If ROI on the platform is total
dog, then you'll start losing advertisers. I think there's a
problem they're running into and they just had to get it fixed.
They had to get it fixed, take the hit for now and and hopefully
keep moving forward. >> Actually wiping out such huge amounts
of bots. I'm hoping they are still going to continue doing this
because there is still work to be done. All of these bot services
are going to do their best to circumvent this so that way their
clients can continue to pay them money for this service. They're
not just going to roll over and die. They're not going to go
belly up and just admit defeat. They This is always a tugof-war.
They are going to come up with new ways of trying to evade Twitch's
detection. And I'm hoping this isn't just like a one-time thing
where Twitch blew their whole load here on this bot blast. I'm
hoping they will continue to allocate resources to fighting against
the upcoming bots that are going to be no doubt surfacing soon.
But either way, this is a great step in the right direction and
I hope it continues. Just wanted to yap about it a bit. That's
it. See you. >> Bye, Charlie. Bye.
What? Hold on. What is this? I got a notification that Asmin
Gold responded to this, so I just checked it out. Ethan Klein
encounters what a top channel on Twitch looks like in 2025. I
don't spend a lot of time on Twitch. Is it normal for chat to
be full of racial slurs? >> Chat, what is happening right
now, bro? >> I feel like you got a
Are you haggling me, bro? >> No. Yo, I think 5K is fair,
chat, cuz he's way better than Ron. And >> I see they're
talking about money and it's LJW in the chat. A lot of LJW in
the chat. XQC.
>> Yeah. Really?
>> Now, one would wonder if if if Dan and if Dan and
Ethan Wasn't Ethan talking about streaming on kick, do we really
as kick streamers want to cast the first stone on people in chat
spamming Lju? Now, that doesn't happen in my chat, but I know
for a fact it happens in Aiden's chat. I in fact, I'm pretty
sure that's a massive meme in Aiden's chat.
No.
Is that not a massive meme in Aiden Ross' chat? >> They're
saying,
"What is chat?" What is happening right now, bro? >> I
feel like you got to the Some got It's got to be. >> So,
you're saying I have to put up more than you basically. >> Yes.
I need odds obviously. Top five in the world. Are you crazy?
>> Top 90. Top 90. Okay. >> Top 90. >> Okay.
Okay. Let me think, chat. I give
All right. I I'll spice this up a little bit. If you beat me
without a coach in the call, I'll give you 10,000. If you >> Are
you haggling me, bro?
>> Asold responds, I know what you might be thinking, but
this actually isn't my chat. Wow. Just stop this stream until
some percent of us. Three in chat.
Okay. I usually expect 10% chat participation at any given time.
Uh, guys, hold on. I'll just do the I'll just do a poll. Hold
on. We'll do a poll for 60 for 2 minutes, guys. Guys, we'll do
a poll for 2 minutes.
Just pick any option on the poll. Okay.
Oh, hold on. One, two, three.
Any option on the poll. There's the poll. Pick any option on
the poll. Even if you are just listening in the background, pick
any option on the poll. Okay? Any option right now. Pick any
option on the poll. If you're listening, pause, pick up your
device, pick any option on the poll. Let's see how many people
actually pull in. Hello. Hello. Is anybody there? I'm expecting
probably about 70 people. Okay, we hit 70 pretty quickly actually.
But keep going. Keep going. If you're there, you need to step
you need to step in. Hit hit any option on the poll. Okay. Any
option.
Go ahead. Pick an option on the poll. Anything you like. Anything
you like. That one guy with alts. Yeah, it's hard to even get
up to like a 100. A lot of people do just listen, right, while
they do other stuff. Yeah, pick any option on the poll. There
are some things. Well, hold on. But I Yeah, I don't even know.
I don't know if bots actually pick options on polls, guys. If
you have not opted in on the poll, okay,
hit any option on the poll. We have about 40 seconds left. If
you've not hit the poll, not hit any option on the poll, that's
not good. Okay,
07. Okay,
get in here. Hit an option on the poll. Any option, any option.
Okay, we got over 100. We got quite a bit over 100. I will just
be your pay.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. How dare you make me get out
of bed to vote? >> I'm literally looking at somebody right
now who's just listening to the stream and I don't know if they
voted. Oh, she voted. Never mind. Uh, you didn't hear that. You
heard that. You didn't hear that. Okay.
So, we hit what? 69 28 23 uh 19 97
120 120. Yeah. Which is like I I don't know about what you'd
expect to be honest with you. 120 120 active plus 300 lurkers.
So, you have about 200 to 300 bots. And I said about a 1.5 modifier,
right?
That's where I'd expect it to be most nights. I'll be real. Want
to change my vote? No. No changing the votes. Okay.
Why? Why? Okay. Um, watch Charlie video. We can look at some
of the channels as well. I don't even think we got through the
whole XQC thread, actually. One second. There's a lot going on
in that XQC thread. I can keep reading it. There's like a lot
of people chatting that XQC thread.
Click on any streamers you want and then tap streams. From there,
I would compare August 21st, 22nd, 23rd to match it up against
usual performance. It gives a good idea of what's happening.
I've been thinking why orgs would bought heavily. Then the answers
seem almost obvious. Talent agencies receive a percentage of
ads from the streamer ad streams their talent does. By inflating
their streamers, they can sell massive ad packages in bulk and
take in much higher sums. To put simply, fraud. This doesn't
seem like a problem for most people, but it's the silent killer.
It kills the whole industry as a whole. It lowers discoverability
for smaller streamers significantly and cuts down their income
if they ever make it at all. I did some digging and shared findings
with others and found egregious instances of streamers going
from 100 viewers daily to 5,000 overnight. I was speechless and
when I noticed they had been doing it for years. The worst part,
a lot of recent streams ended being sponsored. Awful. Uh here's
an absolutely abysmal example of this. The fact that if uh the
fact that this can go on for years without the platform taking
action is just sad really. If Twitch doesn't care, then why should
anyone really followers like not generating any followers but
having thousands of viewers? Bro, why isn't he pulling up names?
That's the crazy thing. This post/ thread will go nowhere. So,
no one will care either. But if I didn't post about it, I'd be
mad at myself if I didn't at least try to raise some form of
awareness before this uh about this before it's too late. I'm
going to bed. In a few days, people will go back to calling me
skits over this. Dude, XQC kind of XQC is right, but like I haven't
been watching him for a long time. Did he just become like train
wrecks? I like I don't know why he wouldn't just post this and
like have just be like this is weird. Not be like nobody will
take this seriously cuz nobody takes me serious. Why why do that?
Why do that? That's weird.
I don't know why he'd do that. This is why charts aren't for
everyone. Like a chimpanzeee with a machine gun. You dropped
a chart with zero context or any attempts to understand it. You
can even see the color of the graph change, which probably means
I means a game swap. Try harder. Oh, that is a little bit true
that like he would have a pretty fast drop off if he switched
to a video game instead. Like going from React to video
Why the hell would Twitch alert streamers that this was happening
ahead of time? Some of the most botted people simply haven't
gone live in the last few days because they know it'll expose
them. If it's proven that these people are botting themselves,
it is likely they're sending fake stats to sponsors, which constitutes
fraud and should be investigated. The fact that NP knew ahead
of time when the crackdown was going to happen should sound all
all the alarms. Huh? Why would anyone on the inside communicate
this? Why anyone on the inside would communicate this is beyond
me. It defeats the very purpose. Clearly, we're still missing
a few pieces of this puzzle. Okay, where's the train? Where's
the train reply? Here it is. Train train was going off. Okay,
in this thread,
crazy part is it's the small midsize size. It's the small midsize
creator who gets the hardest. These large streamers have driven
out hundreds of millions of dollars from multi-billion dollar
companies that have fully pulled out of marketing the marketing
space. If you're going to bot for the appearance of having clout,
please stop accepting accepting sponsorships. You're everyone
else over. Real large creators bring in hundreds of millions
of dollars in deals to each respective platform because their
own personal deals result in the expected amount of conversions
from their real high viewership. However, for viewers, this is
not the case. View botterers who inflate their viewership by
50% or more do not meet conversion requirements that justify
the high pay based on the provided inflated numbers. This is
this then results in the companies exiting the space and blaming
the spaces. So viewers are literally robbing the entire industry
of hundreds of millions of dollars of future revenue for real
creators. This happens because when viewers accept accept sponsorships,
they aren't giving their real viewership. They're instead giving
their inflated botted viewership. And botted viewership doesn't
convert because they're they aren't people. They aren't real
people. So companies unknowingly pay for their product to be
advertised to fake viewers. And when the conversion doesn't meet
the high viewership provided, they don't blame the thing which
they don't understand viewing. They instead blame the market
for not being the right fit for their product and fully exit.
So the viewer gets a quick bag at the cost of the company leaving
the entire space.
There needs to be a distinction between bots and whatever kick
is doing. I mean, uh, Train doesn't like the botting on Kick
either or like the I think it's a modifier. They probably say
they don't. I think it's a modifier personally. I've like I've
never seen any um what do you call it? Like I've never seen I've
never seen them say it or acknowledge it, but to me I it seemed
pretty obvious that like it was like a 2x viewbot or
>> Uh XQC literally provided your narrative of most top
Twitch streamers are botting wrong last night. It's the small
to midsize that bought the most. Bro is so blinded by bias. It's
sad. Your tour understand his point in mine. They're talking
about sponsorships using that to get big sponsorships and then
the industry over. That's what they're complaining about. Small
mid-sized creators bought to appear large. So when I say most
top creators are botting, it's because most of the top creators
are actually small mid-size streamers that bought. Use your head.
Huh. Okay. I thought Train had a whole bunch of other posts around
this. Am I crazy? Go to the replies for Train Rex. Let's see.
Let's see. Let's check it out. Maybe not. Maybe I was wrong.
Maybe he doesn't have a whole bunch of replies around this.
Come on, dude. I guess not. Who read this guy have talked about
how streams on their platforms retain viewers longer when people
leaves. Okay. I used to get captures on my VPN on kick. That
sucked. Ah.
Well, what else we got here? Oh, then there was a Hassan decided
to comment on Tech's loss of viewership. Okay, Teone fell off
because of the
>> Just a lot of people who are invested in right-wing
commentary. That's what I
And I think I was a little wrong about that. I think that there
is, >> by the way, fun fact. Okay. Either Hassan's got
really good tech or Hassan didn't fall off at all. Hassan like
totally carried through apparently and was totally fine. Hassan
lost nothing as far as I
crushed. Hassan transcendent. Hassan might be the biggest streamer
on the platform after all of this. >> The organic audience
for writing commentary is just not as big as I thought it was.
At least on this platform. I mean, one of the biggest like cuts
uh adjust
>> Hi. Uh,
are you talking about the Destiny stuff or if I talk about it,
are you going to >> I
[__] you? >> Uh, no. I mean, I'm I'm doing
some Twitch viewership stuff or sorry, viewer botting stuff,
but that's always a good
Uh, so I I was somebody messaged me saying that the person that
was
uh uh whose name was attached to all this in regards to the Destiny
stuff that it was the wrong person. Any idea about that?
>> I tried messaging them back, but they didn't they haven't
gotten back to me. Um, and I haven't seen anything online to
indicate that. Yeah. I
>> was somebody you trust, somebody you rely on, somebody
you think is >> Yeah, they're pretty they're pretty dependable.
Yeah, they're pretty
>> Okay. Uh did they have any sort of evidence or they
just say that and then not say anything? >> They said that.
I mean, I caught their message late.
>> Um it's not like they we were messaging back and forth
and they just stopped.
>> Fair enough.
>> Other than that, is there any updates that you know
of? I mean, the Willyax stuff came out. >> Yeah, I saw
the the Willyax stuff. It was pretty interesting. Um, >> yeah.
Okay, I got to rise you a little bit. Okay, I got to rise you
a little bit. Uh, what rational self-interest was he serving
by confessing to >> uh sending screenshots of to people
>> to like Willie Mac? >> To Willy Mack. And then
on his stream earlier today or sorry earlier yesterday when he
responded to Willie Mack I believe he said at some point I can't
remember which stream it is now at some point he says yeah we
we were looking for Rose and we I sent screenshot of this. So
he basically confirms that he has some group chat to go and try
to find this person that he was sending screenshots of the videos
to. The date on the video is like August 2022 just two months
before she turns 18. So he's
you know he's I >> I'm sorry. So he's
I didn't catch this. So I I guess I'll just start with the Willie
Mack thing.
>> in regards to the Willie Mack thing, he could just be
trying to come off as transparent to Willie Mack and trying to
be like, "Hey, look, I am actually trying to go through the proper
legal processes to be able to do this." He clearly
didn't think that Willie Mack would do what he did, otherwise
he wouldn't have said it, right? >> Yeah. So he thought,
I'm imagining based on the way he was speaking to Willy Mack
that he probably would have Willie Mack he was hoping that Willy
would probably just go like, "Oh, this guy's trying to go through
proper legal steps to like figure this out." I don't think he
was expecting him to press him on Wait, you got CP on your computer?
I don't think he was expecting that. >> Sure. Um, do you
think do you think the proper legal So he's never mentioned going
to the police, right? I've never seen Destiny. And that to me,
I'm not sure how you could take the proper legal steps without
going to the cops. >> The proper legal steps for having
that on your I don't I don't know what the legals is about. I'm
not a lawyer. I I don't know how that works. >> I would
just imagine
So, so here's just I'll just give you a little logical loop here
and and you could tell me where you disagree. Um, if you had
a child on your computer and
you just said that you were holding it so that something could
be investigated and that was a valid excuse if you'd never informed
any other uh form of authority, then does that not just cover
all child anywhere ever? >> Or what what does that not
cover? What do what do you mean? >> So So basically, if
you say I'm holding this for an investigation if it ever
>> is that not how can not What he said he said so I said
>> just to be clear yesterday he said he had not gone
current lawsuit >> yeah that's a civil suit.
>> So if he if he was informed let's imagine the reality
which I don't believe is the case based on his first response
just to be clear but let's imagine a reality where his lawyer
said do not delete
that CP because it has to do it could have to do with this case.
it could be relevant to this case and you do not want an extra
charge for like destroying evidence. That in theory could make
sense. Um I don't believe that's the case based on his first
response like a material uh uh I don't think that is materially
true based on his first response but that could be the case.
that could exist in theory and that wouldn't cover every single
person who has CP because not every single person who has CP
has an active legal case that could realistically
overlap with their possession of
>> I for one thing I would say I probably can't think of
a reason that it would overlap but
like the the actual videos but I I'm saying that I do not know
if you are allowed to hold that for any reason. Um, I believe
in Florida it is is literally zero tolerance.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know of any reason either. Like
just to be clear, I'm not a lawyer, but even though I'm not a
lawyer, pretty intuitively, I'd stake my claim that if you told
your lawyer, I have seen on my computer and I'm worried it and
then their worry was, well, if we destroy it, it might reflect
negatively on you in this possible court case. I'm pretty sure
in all universes in the multiverse the answer is to hand it over
to the authorities. I don't think or or document it in some way
with the authorities. I don't think there is any
any way where the lawyers are just going to be like keep it on
your hard drive. I I don't think that exists. I can't I can't
fathom that existing. >> Yep.
Which is what Destiny has like said he was told, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, he said fully informed his
>> Yeah. Okay. >> And and maybe I'm wrong. I I'll
be I'll be willing to admit maybe that I'm wrong, but I would
be very very amazed if that is if that is the
the the way that that works.
Um
but who knows, you know. Um but e either way, uh the the in the
Willie Mack video, I think it was pretty well done. Uh I I liked
a lot of the stuff. Uh, I don't understand. Did you understand
his 60 gigs point? Because I don't because he said like, "How
do you know that there's 60 gigs unless you have it, right?"
And I feel like that point was a bit of a miss. No, other than
that though, it was pretty >> Yep. Yeah, it was a miss.
Uh, cuz he was just wrong. And Destiny had a screenshot of her
showing like, "Look, I have 60 gigs in my cloud drive of like
photo sets." Which, by the way, she said photo sets that apparently
wouldn't even include the videos they shot. Oh. Um,
yeah. But, >> um, but I would say so I think that's for
Willie Mack because Willie Mack is probably one of the worst
researchers in all of commentary. That's probably like in terms
of how bad he is at his job. In terms of how bad he is at his
job, he that's like one of the more forgivable mistakes he made
cuz Destiny has a log of him saying like I have like I like she
shot 60 gigs. And I I understand sort of how you make that logical
leap a little bit. Um,
that is true by the way. That is absolutely true.
>> You might like you might you might like his Assan videos.
He didn't do the research for those videos. >> Oh, you
could say he didn't do the research for those videos, but I thought
it was pretty accurate. Um, like >> Yeah, that's that's
why it was accurate. >> What is because Oh, I see. You're
saying he's bad when he does research, he's bad at doing research.
>> Yes. Yes. >> I see. Um,
I mean, I haven't seen like egregious attempts for him to do
research. And I mean, in this instance, this isn't even a research
thing. It would it' just be a reasoning thing. But, uh, yeah,
I know. Uh, I saw the Willie Mack thing. I'm going to I'm looking
at the Ethan thing right now. Uh,
and it seems like he burnt the bridge with with Ethan. He tried
to over this >> kind of. I think he's trying to do the
whole like, oh my god, Ethan's community. You guys know snarking
is bad, right? All this rose stuff, that's all snark. Don't you
know that? That's all snark. Seems like that's what's going on.
You might watch stream from today. So, >> Ethan's No, I
haven't. Uh, nor Destiny's um the uh So, Destiny's response
so far,
has he outwardly denied the
uh idea that she's underage? Because it seems like I haven't
seen anything. It seems like he's just constantly like, "Well,
I still don't know how old they >> I think he said I think
he said we don't know for sure, but it sounds like it sounds
like he's not really
he's not exactly engaging with like where the evidence is wrong,
right? He's just saying, "Well, I haven't seen a reputable source
for this." So, I I wouldn't say he's saying, "Well, she's 17."
But he's gone so far as to say, "Well, even if she was 17, like
I had I had no reason to expect that." he's kind of moved past
sort of going after the evidence of it or anything and just >> they're
directly engaging with well even if she was I had no way of knowing
which is not entirely true. >> And also is it it sounded
like you you looked up some of the in Florida. Is it the case
that if he were if she was 17 and he had it on his computer?
Is that like doesn't matter what she told him? It's like is is
the term statutory? Like it it doesn't matter. You're it's you're
>> I didn't look it up. I looked at the legal mindset video
personally.
>> Yeah. Um Okay. Well, yeah. I was just curious because
I I don't know because I know with uh like having sex with people
who are underage, I'm not sure if it's federal, but it it's like
even if they like lie to you, you're still >> That will
be statuto. Yeah, that will be statuto. From my understanding,
the federal charges for this stuff, it's not statutory. It's
not like quite the same
>> but but I have not looked into them. I've just seen
other people talk about them. So, >> okay. Well, we we'll
see what we'll see what shakes out of that. I was just curious
because yeah, like I said, I told somebody that um or somebody
told me that
uh they got the wrong person. So, I wanted to uh see if you had
heard anything about that. >> I've seen no evidence of
that. Yeah. >> Okay. All right. I'll let you get back to
your uh your drama stuff. >> Viewing stuff. Yeah, for sure.
>> We'll talk soon.
>> Okay. I'm going to hit play on this video. I'll be right
back.
>> Just a lot of people who are invested in right-wing
commentary. That's what I thought. I mean, if you're just keeping
it safe,
>> then you should be able to keep yourself safe when this
is all over in Minecraft.
>> Thank you. Thank you very much for the three DG DG is
>> Thank you. Thank you. >> about that. I think that
there is a organic audience for riving commentary. It's just
not as big as I thought it was, at least on this platform. I
mean, one of the biggest like cuts uh adjusted to their viewership
is like Tech Tone, Asmin Gold, second in command. He's had a
big cut as well. I believe he went from like what what did he
what did he go from?
Sully Gnome. Thank god you were wrong. Yeah. I I I placed a lot
of emphasis on I I placed a lot of emphasis on like organic viewership.
I thought it was like real and I thought it was uh and the reason
Yeah. He went from like 5k or he he went from like 5k viewers
to as soon as the bots went down to 1k 1.5k to 2k. Hassan is
making me learn about their streamers against my will. He almost
he dropped almost 50% of his viewers, but today he begged his
kick YouTube streams to open his Twitch stream on another tab.
Why would you ever think anything the right-wing is doing is
real? Um, I I I look at these numbers as a content creator because
I look at these numbers as a content creator because I'm I'm
matching the the political shift happening in the environment
that I exist in in real
>> Wow. So Huzzan came out kind of laughs at Techone kind
of admits that he was a little bit wrong on everything.
Did Destiny delete his tweet on H3H3? Maybe. I haven't seen it
yet. You want me to check? You want You want me to check? You
can't just check yourself. You want me to go check for you? Okay,
give me a
no, not that one. This one?
No. Uh possibly.
Give me a second. I'll I'll just open it through my docket and
we'll see. Uh it was uh it was this one.
Was this one right here? It is uh
it is not deleted. It is not deleted. Okay. Is not deleted. Honestly
kind of surprised tech had 1k real viewers. Well well share link.
Why share link?
>> On stream a few times and he was just watching random
stuff each time. He doesn't actually cover political stuff that
much.
I think he covers political stuff a lot. All right. Catch you
back with that one. There you go. Oh god. Okay. Um, awesome sauce.
Thank you for the five gifted earlier. I appreciate it. I shut
my alerts off. So, I really I'm sorry that I didn't catch that
right away. I didn't catch that right away. All right. Thank
you very much for the five gifted. Guys, we're continue on with
the Twitch view botting stuff. Listen, I don't know if Tech responded
directly to Assan, but I know Asmin Gold responded. Okay. Asmin
Gold did not like Hassan
on Techone. Okay. He was not a fan. Leave my techie alone
says Asmin
>> Leave my techie alone. Okay. >> Yeah. He went
from like 5K or he he went from like 5K viewers to as soon as
the bots went down to 1K 1.5K to 2K.
Huh. Asminold doesn't reactively defend. He just goes and checks
it out. Interesting. Oh, cuz that didn't really >> What
is Hassan doing? >> Why? Why? >> Hassanabi. Sir,
Hassanabi. Sir, >> it seems like you might have lied a
little bit. >> He asked you to do this. Hassan is making
me and I thought it was uh
Okay, he's reading the chat. Well, should do
that's that classic Hanabi on the ground reporting right there.
That's really what it is, isn't it? Hassanabi's on the ground
reporting.
He's in there. He's in the trenches, so you don't have to be.
So he can lie to you about the things that are actually happening
there. Okay,
very cool. Oh,
bro, people are saying like this apparently in YouTube comments.
Both Queen and Jtock have admitted that Solo sent them this leaks
beforehand. Nope.
I've said this repeatedly over and over again. Solo didn't send
anything with it at all in the original leaks. It was all the
Lord and Southern stuff.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. You see the dip in the Techone
Twitch tracker. Give me a second. Let's pull this up. Let's pull
this up. Let's pull this up. Okay. Can you go Can you just Can
you just Can you just Oh, there's a dot.
>> Oh. That's a rough one.
>> That's kind of a rough one right there. Oof. Oof.
Oof. Yeah, he might have gotten hit. Might have gotten hit a
little bit.
>> Han was right again. Well, I mean, he was botting. Hassan
kind of lied about the numbers, but it looks like probably Tee
was botting a little bit, right?
The spirit of his words were true. Okay, let's try not to go
too hard on that [__] Okay. All right. Let's see
here, bro. What else are we doing here today? Seen a lot of these
memes recently. Okay. seen a lot of these memes.
Seen a couple like this today. Okay, it's good stuff. It's good
stuff, bro. I'm like big time EP right now. Okay, I'm just looking
around.
I've got Zena stuff. I've got We could keep looking at Twitch
view botters. Okay, what else are we doing today?
>> There much else? See, dropped to 1K when he should have
said dropped 1K. Maybe
>> those you YT YT comments are happening because food
shop started reviewing your combo with Solo. Yeah, I think I
think I explained this right. Um, we found because of because
of something in the original leaks.
We found that they described watching a stream.
Somebody went and found that stream and found Destiny was messaging
this person named Rose is coming. Okay. on Discord.
Somebody looked up that Twitter, found that Twitter handle in
a web archive and sent me a picture. I sent that picture to Solo,
said, "It looks like you didn't hide her identity that well.
Maybe you should like help this person cuz I I'm pretty sure
other people will find this eventually. People will dig into
this hard. You should probably help her like make sure her opex's
good." Right.
Also, this guy was a
a little bit of a weirdo. I'll be on I'll be honest. kind of
like trying to get people trying to like get people to dance
for him. It was very weird.
But uh yeah, that's that's what happened. And then he said to
me, he was like, "I'd delete that picture if I were you cuz cuz
she was underage." I was like, "Oh, okay. Take your word for
it. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye." Didn't know the context behind it. That's it.
You have unreleased logs with Solo.
Uh do I? I might. I don't. Well, I didn't save the logs. I'm
just thinking there could be screenshots somewhere, but I didn't
save the logs. I didn't do like a log export. You didn't report
it. The account was deleted. Who am I reporting it to? The account
was deleted. I didn't see any content. Who am I reporting what
to?
>> I see no content. I don't have uh
I' I've not seen that, right? And I have his word saying it's
uh to the ex police. The account's gone
>> to the cyber police. Yeah, I guess I could have done
that. The cyber police
Uh, and this is my thinking entirely, right?
My thinking entirely at that time was this person. These Twitter
links have something that was taken down, so I don't even know
what you're talking about. But what I would say is
um what I thought at the time is oh this person's like trying
to say that they're underage because they don't want me to dig
into who they are at all. Right. >> So
Okay.